Boom and live cheeto. Santina of
gentlemen come u with the hot ones.
Hello Sir. How are you going?
I'm big daddy. Good brother.
Just played a little bit of pool
and lost a game and lost. Lost One.
Ill illegitimately you one, one
illegitimate. You mean lost?
You lost one illegitimately yeah.
Yeah.
Scratching is not a good way to win
or we are scratching the eight ball.
These gentlemen. It is. It is the way
to, when it happens, even to the baskets.
It's a real way to win. I'm
good you. While you can't,
you must control the cue ball.
I have no,
I have no balance over any
of that stuff whatsoever.
I know there's a little red dots on
there. Yeah. It means nothing to me.
Those little red dots are the,
they call that the measles cue ball
in that cue ball they've developed for
television so that you could wash the
ball spin so you know what kind of English
the guy puts on the ball has nothing
to do with the person that shooting
whatsoever. It does. Yeah. It's the
person that like for the, for the most,
it's a very controversial ball.
You really want to get into it.
I do because it has a different reaction
than a red circle cue ball or a red dot
Q ball. Those are the preferred cue
balls have a lot of players. Right,
but the measles cue balls,
it's just maybe the tiniest bit
heavier or the surface is different or
something. But it's still legal. People
use it in tournaments. Yeah. Okay.
But players got, some players got
angry when they came up with it.
They didn't like it.
They like the old cue ball.
That's how precise the reactions are.
When we get to the very top level of pool
players, let's kind of like golf balls,
but people think almost don't
mean anything to golfers. They do.
I'm sure the field is so there's
a lot of soft, softer golf balls.
Like a lot of people like Titlest makes
predicting a provi once or probably one
access harder, softer. He average
Joe who's full of Shit, who's like,
I like Pro v one it doesn't
mean anything to him.
Some guy that's like a 15 or 20 handicap.
It means nothing.
A guy that's like a scratch golfer.
Like a like a pro pool player.
It makes all the difference. Yeah. How
it comes off the face, how it spins.
There's a thing called a mud ball.
If it's buried in mud it, it,
it reacts differently the moment
it comes off the face mud on it,
it's even a little bit right? Yeah.
That mean the tiniest bit that, wait,
can you hear pros?
Impressive bulk offers to as they played
with a bunch of different weights of
clubs.
Yeah.
It's like a pool player basically uses
one cue and maybe one cue to break with
and some players even break
with their playing cue. But you,
you don't have like a bunch of different
cues for a bunch of different shots
usually.
Well this cause the distances but you
just get used to the feel of one cue.
So when a player changes cues,
like say if you go from a 18
ounce Q two at 21 ounce Q,
there's a big difference in
the way it hits the ball,
drives through the ball different. You
have to make the Q do more of the work.
Right.
Heavy with a heavy Q.
Do you think it mentally changes the
way you strike it? Totally, yeah.
That's the Fox and people's heads.
That's what's so impressive about golfers.
They got all these different weights.
Everything's different shape.
It's different. There's a guy, I
think his name is Bryce. Cindy Shambo,
I think that's the golfer he used.
All his clubs are cut to the same length,
which is really rare. Nobody does
that. Like almost every club set
you get is all different
lengths clubs and he is this,
people did it years and years ago,
but he's like one of the only guys on
tour that now cuts his clubs to the same
length cause he mentally wants to have
the same exact stance over the ball no
matter the shot. It's pretty smart.
It's, I mean it's a, it's a cool,
interesting concept. A lot of golfers
don't know how to adjust that much.
I don't know Jack Shit about golf, but
there's guys with weird strokes and pool.
There's guys with weird technique
in boxing and it still works. Yeah.
There's people that do shit different.
There's no way that,
I don't think there's
any right way in sports.
Some of the ugliest shots in basketball
tend to be some of the most fun to watch.
And sometimes they're really good.
Like sometimes like the classic Ray Allen
basketball stroke is probably the most
beautiful jumpshot, you know,
compared to him and Jordan.
But there are guys that
have terrible looking shots,
but they're fucking phenomenal.
It's just,
it's just consistency and their
inner balance over, you know, the,
the timing that they have in
the release that they have.
That's to say that's gotta be the same
thing in every sport pool for same shit
for sure. In boxing too. Yeah. You know,
in boxing it used to be thought
that you pretty much, you know,
if you went to a good trainer, they
would teach you to keep your hands up.
Those always the way to box. But then you
get to a level of like a Tommy Hearns.
You remember the way Tommy
Hearns used to fight?
He used to keep his left hand low.
Really low. Yeah. Down to the side.
And he would snap that left hand at
you like a fucking let Colebra man is
cracked motor city Cobra. He would just
pop that fucker right in your face.
That's why they used to call them that
because it was coming out of fucking
nowhere. Hitman, Tommy Hearns.
He was a bad motherfucker dude.
And then he would hit you with that right
hand and he had so much torque cause
he was really wide. He was really
long and wide for a welterweight man.
You'd look at him in 147 pounds.
I think he was probably like six two and
just shred hatch act and just Korean 47
at six two is lightweight champ.
You're see what he looked like when
he fought sugar ray Leonard. Uh Huh.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
And then he went up to one
60 fought Hagler and got k
owed by Hagler and a crazy
slug fest. You never saw that. Fine.
Pull up Marvin Hagler versus Thomas
Hearns. This might've been the great,
I think it went two rounds,
but it might've been the greatest two
rounds in the history of the middle weight
division because these two guys
were super skilled. I mean,
Marvin Hagler was a
brilliant technical boxer,
can switch from south pod
orthodox like fluidly like you,
you didn't even notice a difference.
He fought just as good from both sides
and he knocked everybody out and had an
iron chin and Tommy Hearns was
mark and motherfuckers. He mark,
Roberto Duran with one punch. It's blank
face planted on fucking one punch, man.
He's titty. Stung with one shot
and let me let them see that first.
Here's the buildup. The buildup
is Tommy Hearns, [inaudible],
Roberto Duran.
Let's watch that first and then we're
going to go back to Marvin Hagler versus
Tommy Hearns. So you get a feel for what
it was like to be able to switch up.
Your stances is so crazy to me to be
able to do that so fluidly that well,
that's one of the brilliant
things about Hagler.
I mean he was just so good
at that and he get in.
It's weird for a guy when you're used to,
I remember the first time I
fought a guy who was left handed.
It was super confusing.
Everything's coming from the wrong place.
Everything was like reversed.
You gotta get used to it, right?
You don't see it as often, right?
So if you don't see it as often,
sometimes it's more effective. But some
guys are really good. Again, southpaw,
some guys have like a
lightning right hand.
And that was one of the speculations
about Hagler and Hearns cause Hearns had
this lightning right hand and
Hagler oftentimes fought south pot.
And that's the counter for south
hall is a, is a straight right. Now,
watch this though. This is just goes to
show you how God look, how big he is.
Rude. She's look at
this. Ooh, come on man.
When Tommy Hearns Merck
people, he's marked people
and you've got to understand,
man, he did this to Roberto Duran.
That's fast in slow motion, dude,
he was so fast, fast, even
in fucking slow motion.
He was so fast and he hits so hard,
but now you've got to watch this
and this is Hagler in his prime.
He was 30 years old who was the undisputed
mother fucking middleweight champion
of the world and most people thought
he's the best pound for pound fighter on
earth and Tommy Hearns of course you
just saw what he did to Roberto Duran and
it was a lot of speculation,
a lot of speculation coming into this
fight and they just went at it from the
beginning of the round.
There was very little feeling.
It was just constant pressure by
Hagler right hooks, boom, boom,
we this bro, they, they're going to war.
These are two of the best fucking
middleweights ever and they're standing in
front of each other, go wing to war and
it doesn't feel like anybody's faced.
It feels like there's, it
feels like they're at the
exact same energy level too.
Oh Dude.
Both of them are.
They have the same output
look fucking crazy fight Matt.
And they were throwing full power shots
from the moment the fight started and
they right in front of each
other. Man, if for Hearns this,
this negates is gigantic reach
advantage over almost everybody. Yeah.
So Hearns decided to fight this way.
He decided to stand right and look at him.
The referee could barely separate herds,
decided to stand right in front of Hagler
and haggard decides to have right in
front of her aunts and they
just now Hearns is moving.
See now this is what Hearns could have
done from the beginning and made it
interesting. Sticking and moving. But
by the time he decided to do that,
he was already touched up and Marvin
starts moving in for the kill that left
hand to the body.
Hagler was relentless in his
cardio was fucking supreme.
It was supreme. He always put pressure
on people and you couldn't have hurt him.
He only had one bullshit knocked down.
His entire crew is a bullshit knocked
down. He fly. I think it was one role,
Dan and won role.
Dan kind of like,
it was more like a shove and maybe maybe
they tripped or something like that.
And the referee called it a knockdown.
But I remember thinking God,
cause Hagler had a weird thing that
he was either born with or developed.
He had giant muscles on
the side of his head.
Like he was temple worn with head gear.
I'm not bullshitting.
They had him and this was like a big
thing in the world of sports back in the
day like that. He was literally almost
born for this. That's how good Hagler was.
Yeah. These motherfuckers are really,
I mean it's relentless do their,
they're towed up every time it's up there.
Barely look looking for any
distance between each other.
And you got to realize,
man,
this is not how people usually fight.
They don't throw full
power shots and every shot,
I mean they'd be tired within 15 seconds.
These guys are just going at it.
So I think this was like
almost like a game of chicken.
Like both of them knew there were never
going to reach the 12th round. Right.
So they said fuck it,
let's just do this.
And haggard just stood right in front
of them, constantly blasted them.
And you see at the end of the first round,
Hearns is wilting.
He just does not have the
power or the speed or the
movement. See, he's all goofy.
Yeah, he's sloppy. He's just
exhausted. He is exhausted.
But still the warrior in him is making
him throw these fucking bombs, man.
You got to realize like at the time,
no one really knew what the fuck
was going to happen in this fight.
And then Hagler heard them.
Yeah.
There's a little stumble in one of
one of hagglers incredible attributes.
Besides his skill was his
determination to win. Man,
he was just Keizer for Roche's
competitor, man. Just ferocious.
And so if someone was willing to
engage him in this kind of crazy fight,
we're going to stand toe to toe and
see who's the bigger man. Oh my God.
Everyone's going to die.
That is going to take you to the end of
the earth man to the end of the earth.
I mean, haggler just looked like he just
had, it's still so much left in the tank.
Even at the end of the first round,
like if he's not doing this for years,
he's never had a shape. He never
partied. He never did anything stupid.
What did he didn't want any short? No,
never got fat. No drugs, no alcohol,
no nothing. No. And how about this?
Retired after the sugar ray Leonard
fight lost a controversial decisions.
Sugary Lennar to, to this day, I think you
won. And then, but it was a close fight,
but and then just retired and became
a fucking movie star in Italy.
That's fucking wild. Love that guy.
Yeah, but that's the way to do it.
I'll kind of go out of the good
prime and then just say good night.
Nobody else did it like him, man.
Nobody else did it. Like, Ooh,
that's where you heard him. Yup. Now
he's just moving in for the kill.
Move in for the kill.
Now he's taking his time.
See now it's just nice and relaxed.
This is inevitable.
Now Marvin is just moving in and
decide and when he's going to uncork,
when he's going to uncork moving in,
blocking these shots, he knows it.
Hearns is hurt and he
starts teeing him up.
Shanahan and Hearns is
trying to move down.
See now that's how I thought
Hearns was going to fight. And Mo,
most people thought Hearns is
going to fight from the beginning.
Like that just keep me down.
Got moved from the outside,
from the outside like that.
I mean that's,
that's classic Thomas Hearns but the
warrior and him wanting to find out,
you know, and want to find out who's the
baddest motherfucker in town. Who is it?
You know, you could fit you and you
can feel him backing up. Kinda he,
he knows what's kind of,
it's like he knows what's coming.
He, he's getting in some good shots.
Even then he's creating distance,
but even still, it just doesn't feel like
he's balanced. See that right there. Oh,
he's hurt. Haggar standing right in front
of him. He is touching him, but he's,
he just doesn't have the pop anymore.
You know what it's like when you're
working out and at the end of the workout
you're fucking exhausted and
you could barely do one rep.
That's what happens with your arms
when you're fighting. It just,
there's nothing left. There's nothing
left. It's not like, you know,
he's doing this on purpose.
Right. He's, he doesn't have it.
There's no gas in his arms, like his
arms are completely flooded right now.
Like all the blood in them and every,
it's just they're not recovering.
It's a horrible feeling to, he's
swinging though. Look, he's swinging,
but it's way slower than it was the
first round. Right. His snap was,
snap was so much quicker in
the first round and now he's,
now he's not following
through a little bit. Exactly.
He's trying to conserve energy.
He realizes he can't do this forever.
He's exhausted God there, but they both
look like they're fucking at that one.
That little breaking point
where it's about to be either.
I'm telling you it Hagler
even though he might,
it might look like that because it is a
fast pace. He could do this for years.
He says they can do this. He
just didn't get tired, man,
and you couldn't hurt him. He was crazy.
He fought a dude named John the beast.
Mugabi and John the piece when Gabby
was fucking terrifying people, man,
he starts Terry Norris. He starts to
bunch of dudes. He was a heavy puncher,
heavy puncher and Hagler stood right in
front of them and he got caught with one
big upper cut and it didn't even budge.
Upper cuts that were like Merck and
people didn't even, he didn't even flinch.
So what round was it? Was it the third
round of the third year? The third round?
Here's the third round right here.
It shows you how fucking tough
Tommy Hearns was. I mean,
those two rounds were just
fucking knockout. Drag out.
Relent. Yeah, just nonstop.
But towards the end, you clearly see
hagglers coming on. I mean, he looks good,
he looks good and he's pacing himself.
Now he's just, just moving forward,
throwing shots. But yeah.
Hearns is exhausted, man.
It's fucking raw. Rough man.
There it is. Boom, boom, boom.
Or just trying to keep it and
I was trying to keep him right.
He's having a hard time breathing
though, man. I mean, he's exhausted.
See that big deep breath.
What are you take that Big Sigh?
It's almost like not, uh, somebody
lost a mouthpiece, I think.
Is that what it was? He called his time.
Yeah. I think that's what happened.
I Dunno man. It's hard to tell.
It's really blurry for this.
Just going to say Amanda to
two 40 p was weird back then.
Hod look normal to us back then. Your
eyes knew how to handle it, right? Well,
you were just excited that you could see
the fight. Right. You know, but this was,
it was,
I wonder if this,
would it look like when it's on HBO
had to vent a little bit on those TV.
Do you know Hbo just canceled boxing?
They don't have boxing anymore
at all. At all. Just paper view.
Now they don't even do pay per view.
They're out of the boxing business. What?
Yeah, and that crazy. So they'll never end
and he's moving boom, right hand.
Oh, it's does it. He knew it.
Damn. Dance it. Third round
gone. I always miss this.
I always think it's just
hanging around for some reason.
I think we've actually gone over this
before, but third round. Yeah man.
But I don't have boxing anymore.
HBL got out of the boxing business.
What do you think that's because of
it's not earned enough money anymore.
I don't know.
It makes me sad though.
They had some of the greatest
boxing telecast of all time.
I mean that was what you would do.
You'd go if a big fight was
on Bernard Hopkins was on,
a lot of the times it was on
HBO and it was on paper view.
Then you knew it was going to be
on HBO the following week. Right.
So even if you couldn't
afford the pay view,
you could see the hang in there
a week later. You knew who won,
but you could watch the fight on HBO.
I remember going to watch,
I remember watching fights in Hpo.
I just remembered that let let HBO boxing
being such like a emblematic thing for,
you know what I mean?
It's so recognizable.
So like pay view on Hbo so them
get out of the game is so strange.
It's kind of like the
revolution that's happening now.
The last fight I went to with you at
UFC, now their ESPN, what does it plus?
ESPN plus. That's what it
is. Private paid service.
It's a subscription service, like
a Netflix for sports, but it's,
it's not just UFC fights. It's,
it's a bunch of other stuff. Wow.
All kinds of shit and stuff. They
just won't show on ESPN at Aldo? No,
they sometimes show you
mean it's ESPN content?
I guess so you could watch some fights
that were on ESPN plus later they'll
probably show him on ESPN. Sort of like
the same thing with Hbo pay per view,
you know, but um, I think
what HBO did with Paper View,
it was brilliant where you
would have the paper view,
but then let people watch it for free.
A week later you're just
going to make more fans. Yeah.
It's like you're not going to
lose money on the paper view.
I'm just going to make more fans.
Well that's the whole idea of like a,
that's why this, this, this
is funny. I was going to talk
to you about this anyway.
I just moved and I cancel my
directv. I'm done. I canceled them.
I cut the wire and I'm just doing
like a Hulu live TV, Internet shit.
All the years of hearing people being
like cutting the cord, cutting the cord.
I'm like, I dunno man. I like it now. Fuck
it. I love, I love what I'm doing now.
And I gotta Tell Ya,
I can get all the shit that I want
for cheaper than I had it before.
And it's just way more convenient now.
I used to be so tethered to being like,
I'll never give up cable now. I'm like,
fuck it. I don't want it anymore. I don't,
I don't want it.
This has been the best version.
I'll always have a blockbuster
card. Oh yeah. It'll never go away.
It'll never Hollywood video,
dude, I want to rent, man.
If you put all your money in that he like,
I'm telling you in 20 years this is going
to amount to $15 million fucking Klan.
Do you think people invested in Netflix
when it was the DVD subscription service
and that, you know what I mean, like early
on and now they're still getting the,
the revenue dividends of what Netflix
is now. I wonder about that. Oh yeah.
I'm sure you do.
Like,
that's gotta be the best money cause
it was worth nothing back then.
It was just another subscription
video service and they had,
there was a ton of them. I mean Red Fox.
I did my first Netflix special in 2005.
Oh my God, there's one
left. Oh, I think I've
seen this. Oregon. Here you go.
Yes. An Oregon, Oregon Bend, Oregon.
That's so weird to last.
Blockbuster.
They went from 4,855 stores
in 2008 to one store.
2018.
That is the craziest demolition
of a business I've ever heard.
I wouldn't never heard of
what other business in our
lifetimes vanish like that.
Like, uh, like I've come
or like a storefront.
I can't think of something that went
away that quick little industry gone.
It was John. It was a part of our weekend.
Yeah. You go to plop buster. Huge.
What do they got right?
Ah, you hear anything about
this? He'd look at the cover.
I don't know that I never
even heard of this one.
Maybe it's good watching like obscure
Dolph Lundgren movies that were made in
Italy. Yeah. You would, you'd get to
pick out shit that you're like, ah,
this looks kind of dope. We'll
see. Back then. Gamble was fun.
The name meant a lot like it was like
this guy from dances with wolves.
Oh, okay. Remember that guy? I can. Cool.
You'll take a chance. Yeah, you will.
You will. But I think that's
happening again now with Netflix.
I'll take a chance with
shit now that I've,
Shit I've never heard of because Netflix,
you pop up all these different
titles and you'll go, hmm,
I'll try this fucking shit.
I just started a new show I just tried
to show and it's called dead to me with
Christina Applegate. Christina
Applegate. Yeah. It's okay.
But like I try, I'll try it. I
would have never think to, to, to,
to watch this new show
about these, you know, this,
have you gone through all the staples at
Netflix? Said, did you watch Ozarks yet?
Done? Watched both seasons. Phenomenon.
One of the best shows I've ever seen.
Did you watch unbreakable Kimmy Schmidt?
Now I've seen a few episodes of it,
but I fucking hilarious. She gets f
people like it. But I love that show.
It's so silly at the same kind
of tone as 30 rock. Right.
Does it say it's Tina again?
Tina Fey's in it too. Oh she is.
Sometimes she plays this
wacky psychologist. It's
out of her fucking mind.
Likes to party. Yeah, she craves David.
She has some of the best
character development man.
That's why 30 rock was so good. That show
is funny, man. Kimmy Schmidt is funny.
All right, I'll, I'll watch it. I'll try
it. It just didn't seem like my show.
It's absurd. You gotta give
it a chance, right? It becomes
really, it's really good.
That's why it was like a some dull
moments and one of those series,
but they tightened it up
quick. They, whatever problem
they have with the writing,
they've fixed it real quick.
Right. Well, I mean, first
seasons are always hard, man.
Well, I mean just writing is hard.
Yeah. Writing for a Sitcom so hard.
They hit ruts sometimes, you know? Yeah.
Like sometimes I'll watch old Seinfeld
when they pop on and some of the episodes
are just fucking flawless there.
Bangers like everything to be stories.
Just as funny as a story and
it's, sometimes you watch a
few and you're like, Huh,
yeah. They were like, they
had a tough week tunic.
You could tell they had a tough go. I
remember that feeling with the news radio.
I remember like episodes where just like,
Ooh,
well we did our best and that's
all there was this one. Yeah,
let me see what happens. They just
don't, and then you'll have the next one.
That's just insane. And a lot of
times it's, it's like stand up in that
sense that a lot of times
it's just like the subjects,
like what are the subjects?
Like what,
what juicy topic do you have?
Right. You know, what, uh, what,
what is happening? And you just, yeah.
You have to have something that engages
people and sometimes it's sitcoms.
Like fuck, you have to put out
20 something episodes a year,
2123 right.
23 short stories in a year.
I make them all tie in and have a nice
little kind of a perfect through lifelong
season. I know what nowadays a lot
of people relying on on politics,
which I think is, you know,
it's becoming the new norm.
Every time I see a billboard
now it's a new political show.
It's like a why it's
seen act just got one.
Jordan Klepper who was a daily show
correspondent. He just got another one.
Hassan Manoj as his, I mean there's
like so many political shows now. They,
they should all be writing
letters thanking Trump.
It's like Trump is really fueling all
these new shows. If it weren't for him,
it was like this new wave of political
satire. I don't think I've had,
I've seen this in comedy in my career.
I've never seen this many shows
about politics. Samantha Bee,
I mean I just named five in a row.
John Oliver show is right that
last week tonight or whatever.
That's essentially a political base show.
It's, it's slightly political, but it's
very social too. Yeah, it is. It's,
it's fucked up right in the week.
He's, I mean, listen, he's brilliant and
some of these shows are probably great.
I just think there's so much
political comedy right now. It's just,
it's not my shit.
No. Oliver's excellent.
Yeah. He's a genius.
The whole thing is what's,
what's uncomfortable is that it's very,
they're very little conversations taking
place and a lot of people that are like
really angry. Yeah. You know? Yeah.
I was watching this guy, some,
some representative,
I don't even know his name,
but he was a offering a hundred dollars
to name the these girls that were in
front of a,
um,
planned parenthood and um,
he's like a grown man that these, they're
girls, they're young Christian girl.
What do you mean name them as
in like call them out games
so he could shame them publicly. Cool.
Very smart. This guy's named name and,
but he's an offering on this video.
$100 like,
but this is where people have gotten to
where they think that that's okay. Yeah.
Like these people you have like,
do,
I know you're there to support
a woman's right to choose,
but you have to understand that these
people think that this is a place where
they kill babies. Yeah. Right.
This is what they think.
Whether regardless of what you think,
right. This is why they're there.
They're not there because they're evil.
Right.
And I know that this would put unwanted
pressure on a girls going there for an
abortion. I get it. I get the whole thing.
I get it from your side and I see
where they're coming from too.
And although I fully support
a woman's right to choose you,
you can't want to dox people that think
they're saving babies or talking someone
into having a child and
that they think we'll
become the kind of relationship with
that child and that mother become like
their mother and them or like
the ideal version of that. Sure.
I mean that's what they're, they're not
doing it because they're bad people.
Right?
Like there's some groups that do it just
because they're pieces of shit like the
Westboro Baptist church. Like they
do things because they're bad people.
Like all they want to do is go
protest a soldier's funeral.
I didn't want to cause a stir Megan Phelps
who left them, right, that got out. Yes.
Yeah. And now, dude, she met a guy
on Twitter. It's a great store,
right? It's an amazing human. Again. Well,
she started talking to people and then
investigating and real and dude, wow,
I'm telling you, when you talked
to her, she's like the nicest,
most reasonable person. Right? To think
that just 15 years ago, whatever it was,
10 years ago, she was a full on zealot.
It's weird. And her dad or uncle,
grandfather, brother can't even get it
right? Her grandfather is the Fred Phelps.
He started the whole thing. He's
the old dude, that old mean guy.
But do you think it's fact you bill,
you completely do you completely buy into
the fact that she's a hundred years of
it?
So none of that's underneath while she's
so honest and open about what she felt
and why she felt it and why
she was conflicted and why
it didn't jive with what
she was reading in the Bible. It
didn't make sense to her. Right. And,
and the way he was doing it,
which she was realizing was
not how Christians did it
all over the world. Right.
And that this, this, you know,
this desire to constantly
get attention in the news.
Even at soldier's funerals,
they would go to soldier's funerals
and say that these soldiers are dying
because gay people are getting married.
Like what they were saying,
they deserve to die. They deserve to
be dead. I mean that kind of, you know,
but I'm telling you from that she's like
the nicest person you'd ever want to
meet. So she up in and regulation in
her world, she realizes it was bullshit.
She was tricked and you know,
she's done a great job to free herself.
But when you indoctrinate
someone heavily into anything,
and this is whether it's being a religious
zealot or being a political salad,
you indoctrinate someone when they're
early in their, their, their youth,
a formidable years. Very difficult for
them to get out of it. It takes real work.
But that's what I mean. I that's right.
I guess I'm saying it sticks with you,
right? Like my whole thing is there's
things instilled in me from my youth,
from where I grew up culturally and
how I grew up that even though I'm more
learned now, I still do understand
those ways of thinking. Right?
So it is hard to break
away from those things.
Even though like when you just said the
whole like w a woman's right to choose,
right? Like I grew up in the
Midwest, I grew up Catholic.
This is how I am most of my family is
for so in so many words against abortion,
uh, but I don't think these things are
mutually exclusive that you can be against
abortion and against
women's rights to choose.
You can say that you don't like abortion,
but also say I'm not going to
control what you do with your body.
It's kind of how I feel. I don't love
the idea of abortion. I'm being honest.
I just,
I just don't love it.
But I do think I'm not going to stand
here and tell people what to do,
but I should be able to still say
I don't like it. I don't think it's, I
don't think it's a healthy thing to do.
I don't really enjoy,
I don't enjoy like the spreading of it
being kind of this not a big deal thing.
But I do think people can do
whatever they fucking want to do.
But I'm also allowed to go. Uh, I
don't, I don't, I don't love the idea.
Like I don't like it. Uh, just as
an option. I just don't love it.
I don't love it. Birth
control is obviously the
best method. Yeah, of course.
And I think women should be more aware,
but women, when they take birth control,
man,
they have to,
I'm not not advocating for abortion
as a method of birth control,
but what I'm saying is when
women take birth control pills,
that shit fucks with them. The fuck's
with their horse, not a good thing.
It's not good. And that, I know. And,
and when they do it in, they also smoke.
They can cause like real
complications. It can, it's a lot.
I mean there's a lot of women have really
bad reactions to the pill changes your
behavior, suicidal tendencies. I, I've
heard a lot of like really bad stories.
Now I'm also saying if we want to look
at it from a different perspective,
men should also take way more
fucking responsibility then like,
this is the other side is this,
this argument tends to land on women a
lot where it's like you don't tell me how
to fucking, you don't tell a woman
what to do with the body is like, okay,
that's fine. I'm just saying
how I don't like it. Also,
I don't like guys nutting in women and
fucking ghosting and not wanting to raise
a child.
Right?
So I think the other side of it is two
parties here should be responsible.
Men should take some
fucking responsibility over,
stop common inside of these fucking
people. If you're not ready to have kids,
I'm just being real. It's like
either wear a condom or stop, stop,
stop doing the thing that you know,
makes children. So, you know, but again,
this is this weird balance of,
like I say, I come from this
and I am not conservative, but like this
real Catholic upbringing in the Midwest,
you know,
a good old Irish Catholic boy and the
ideas that you hear as a kid all the time,
you then grow and I now go,
I think people should be able
to do whatever they want to do.
I'm not going to fucking control somebody.
Mm.
But I still have those little moments
of, yeah. I just don't love it though,
because it was something
that was instilled in me as
a youth, you know? I mean,
it's the same way for years. I felt
guilty smoking pot because that was like,
I've been smoking pot for 20 years,
but I felt guilty for a long time cause
my pa because drugs were so bad. Yeah.
It was just like this over. And even
today, sometimes I get high and I go,
should I be getting high today?
Do I have shit to do? Do I, am I,
am I doing something wrong? No, no. I'm
a grownup. I have all my shit together.
I sure
I'm allowed to get high.
You're one of the few comedian friends
that I know that has their shit together.
You're grown up trying to just stay,
stay having my shit together.
You can just tear your shit. It's a
hard task though, right? It's not easy.
Especially for immature dip
shits like us. Yeah, it's,
we're not suppose this isn't supposed
to have. Nikki Glaser had a funny,
she was on stage two and a bit and she
just had said this phrase and I kept
talking to her about it afterwards. She
was like, we don't deserve this money.
And I was like, what do you mean we don't
fucking, and we just, and she's like,
we just don't deserve this much
money for being so immature.
I was like,
I guess that's Kinda true.
Like we get to be clowny kids and still
make a good living. Meanwhile, the guy,
there's a guy who's an electrician
at my house the other day,
the shit he was telling me I couldn't
fucking keep, I mean he sounded,
he was speaking fucking another
language and I had no, I was, he's like,
all you have to have another ground.
Cause the neutrals are different.
How this is a two wire system back
in 1946, you got to have three weeks.
It's going on and on and on and on.
I was like, you deserve more money.
Like you're worth more money. I don't
know why I have more money than you do.
You do much more important shit.
It's all about with our guest with
money, right? It's all about reach.
You know what we were talking
about earlier today about
how much money Facebook
and Google and all these people make from
ads and how weird it is that like you
look for something, then instantly
those ads start popping up constantly.
I am referencing Sam Harris's podcast
again. I don't remember which one it was.
It was fairly recently. He had a
guest on and they talked about the,
uh, the, the commodity
of your data, right?
The commodity of your searches and
who's selling that and how they're,
how they're profiting off of that and
that this was like this commodity that
nobody thought they were giving up. Then
nobody thought there was anything to it.
Right?
Then these companies have found this
loophole and have made billions of dollars
through it by giving you free email,
by giving you a free web browser,
right? By giving you free searches,
basically providing you with all
the information in the world, right?
What they want from you is want
to know what you're interested in.
That's all there'll be.
It's kind of like the real
world example would be, uh,
those trash companies that are like,
you have a garage full of shit will
come pick it up for free. Right?
You don't know what's in that fucking
garage. Some people are so old,
they just throw shit out and they go, ah,
I just get rid of it. Fuck it. You know,
you know those storage wars shows,
I guess they fake. Yeah, they do.
They set them up. They
load up the, the storage.
We believe we found a world
war two helmet. It's Elvis.
His underwear was unbelievable.
Yeah, they used to be real.
Actually a few of them were very
real and then they are very,
then they got caught online.
A bunch of people online,
we're calling them out being like,
this is bullshit. This is fake.
I saw them setting it up like they
got, they got caught. But that's,
they're going to do that. They should
find magic in there and say this is fine.
Should definitely shit storage wars
where they go in there and they find a
Leprechaun. The gap around
makes you disappear. Yeah.
One person disappears and they have a
genie in a lamp and that's gotta be worth
treating me like I'm really stupid. Have
you ever watched the show ghost hunters?
Do you know who it goes to? The
ventures. Do you know this Guy Zach bag?
Zak bagans. Do you know this guy? I
do not know him personally. Oh Man.
He makes me laugh so fucking hard because
they've done like nine seasons now.
I don't even know how many they
found any ghosts come out, man.
They have all this great technology
now that you think that he believes in
ghosts. Here's the best part.
Okay. He is all in, right?
I love anybody that's all in
whatever they're doing to have to be.
The host is all his adventure,
but also now he's super self aware of
their popularity and of his character
caricature of himself.
So he does it now on purpose.
He took off his shirt
when episode and he goes,
you want to fucking fight me ghost?
Let's fucking go to tow up.
Throw a fucking punch.
You're like,
he's aware of his character that
is this broey ghost fist fighter.
This dude is Brennan shop and shop.
That was on episode. Look at him.
He looks like he just got along from
Shane Carwood sparring sessions. Yeah,
he's still in the fight. He's still
out of it. And so this is Zach is what?
The beard? No, Zack is that dude
right there, right? So Zack,
where's Ed hardy type of shirts,
right? He wears these loud,
ridiculous, he patterned shirts, but he's,
you got to see it do with
more newer episode produce,
do something from like 2009 to 18.
You'll see what he looks like now.
He's gotten way more fucking jacked. His
hair, his hair is all flaked up. You know,
he's gotten like more tan around and shit.
He's become,
do you think this becomes super self
aware that he believes in ghosts? No,
I think he's just self aware of
the product he's created really,
that he understands
now that's a challenge.
I see the next whiskey ginger
podcast, me and Zack, Zack, Zack,
that's him right there, right?
Like now he's like, Holly, what?
He looks like a Hollywood guy. He's
got these big black frame glass. Funny.
Like you can't, he can't
look any better. You know,
you're not allowing him to have
better style like that when Hollywood,
you're so Chicago, it's fucking good as
fucking Hollywood flog this spiky hair.
He went Hollywood the fall.
I'll tell you.
That's the one thing I know I
won't do is uh, like I'll never,
I'll never get to a place when I'll be
wearing clothes where I used to make fun
of them like that.
Like I remember going,
sky's wearing a fucking $900 tee shirt.
I know now I can't do that.
Like I can't, I can't get,
I can't do that now cause I used
to shit on it so much. Yeah.
You have to mind by the
rules of your own mall. If I,
if I pushed it out there for so long,
let's say he's got a nice hats him. Yeah,
it looks good.
I has had Jamie that your buddy and say
the breath recent photo I could find.
Jamie, do I zoom in real quick? I
thought you were trying to say something.
Is he handsome fellow? Cute Guy. Jamie,
I want you to grow your facial hair
just like that. You really think,
do you really think he
doesn't believe in ghosts?
I think he does not believe in ghosts.
I think he,
I think he loves the paranormal, right?
He loves the idea of the paranormal.
I think he loves the idea of forces
that nature happening. Molecules,
energies around us, all
influencing the way we act. Sure.
I don't think he believes in actual
apparitions or what do they do?
They call him s uh, uh, spirits
on his EVP. We felt the spirit,
they'll do this thing where they'll
see a little orb or a light.
This happens all the time with cameras
when you switch to night vision and not
these little deaf flecks of dusk
kind of reflect light off the lenses.
And he'll go, what's an orb? And
they'll watch it float through the Lens.
And he's a, he is obsessed about
these orbs. They enter the orb
and he does this voiceover shit. He
got lots of fucking jail. I get hired,
I watch it. It's maybe one of my
favorite things. What's the, Jamie,
you're a photographer. What's the, um,
scientific explanation for those little
balls that show up in photographs?
What is it?
Um,
I don't have the knowledge for that,
but it can be explained in lots
of different ways. It's mostly,
it probably like a light flare
of some kind just because there's
just like in this dose you
stammered through that. So bad,
terrible fucking joke. Tography
science. But like in this lens here,
there's like five
different pieces of glass.
So there's just at whatever
angle you're holding it,
depending on where the light
source is coming from, right.
It might create an artifact,
which would be a little circle if you're
dealing with a really nice camera like
that one.
But what about like with one of them
bullshit zipping and shoot ones,
then they're using that
less, uh, just why there would be some
on that. It's probably because it's less,
it's less good. It's, it's
has less, not the right word,
but a less technology in
there. I don't know. I don't,
I can't explain it honestly.
Well, wines, we should Google it because,
or Glover's right now are freaking out.
Oh my God,
they are angels there in front of you.
Anytime in or passes near a human,
he'll go watch chose reaction as
the orb goes behind his hand. Yeah.
And you change your eyes or your
thighs will change. It was amazing.
You don't believe in fucking ghost.
I believe in every,
you don't believe in guns
all in with everything locked
that foot back scattered.
Here you go back scatter,
back scatter.
The artifact can result from
the backscatter or retro
reflection of light from
airborne solid particles such as dust or
part, but I sell it. Or liquid droplets,
especially rain or mist can also be
caused by foreign material within the
camera's Lens. So these dots are
blurred images of dust particles.
M night Shambhala,
Ding Dong should make a movie
in that movie and it should be called
backscatter. Call him that anymore.
That's really rude. Is it though?
It's kind of funny. It's Sean Milan.
That's his fucking [inaudible].
I'm [inaudible].
You turn on the day you started it. You
fucking put it on me. What are you racist?
What's wrong with you man? He makes
them good God damn movies, the guy,
he takes some crazy risks. But uh, I love
the sixth sense. That was a great fuck.
Come on. Every, I love the village.
People didn't like that and see,
I thought the bill was the end of it. I
was like, where, what about planes? They,
they, they don't, they don't
show any planes going over.
It would have to be to
avoid all the planes.
Well they have to be in a shepherd plain
to places where no planes flying remote
cause they made it out so the road and
then instantly the guy to the road and
people are like, Hey, I like what
they're like Saint Louis. It's like right
there. You know what I liked though?
His ghost. No Devil. The one was in the
elevator. That was a good one. Yeah,
it was good. That was good. That's
good. Well he takes chances.
He takes a shower like,
hey wait, that's this.
This reminds me of you tell when you talk
about that island, that private island,
do you know, sent in a lot, sent,
sent or sensible or central island
planes still fly over that or no.
Are they not allowed to sign
it as a restricted airspace?
I don't think it's restricted.
No,
but you can't land there
and you can't circle. Right.
You can't visit India owns it,
right?
Doesn't the co it doesn't India control
of leaves and it's like 10 mile radius.
I saw a thing online that said a boat
crash there and you could still see on
Google images the remnants of the boat.
Yeah.
They came for the people in the boat too.
And the helicopters got them off the boat.
Right as the people were like pulling up
and I'll say they live and shit. Yeah.
Fuck yeah, they, they live. But those, the
villages were common for them. Oh yeah.
Can you imagine stepping across a village
they've been fucked with sometime in
the past? You know that a commander
Maurice Avi, Dow Portman. Yeah. Guy. Yeah.
Shout out to a respectable
law on, uh, Twitter.
He has a, a, a giant thread about it.
It may be pinned on the top of
his Twitter page, but explaining,
uh, like one of the reasons why
those people are so hostile. Right.
And it has to do with this British
explorer who was really kinky and, uh,
you went there to fuck. Who knows, we
want to fuck island. He was what he did.
But people got sick because you know this,
I had this Guy Graham Hancock on yeah.
And he was talking to me about, um, uh,
all the different shit that they're
finding in the Amazon and in South America
and that they used to be 20 million people
that live in the Amazon and they died
off because of sickness.
They were visited mostly,
apparently Europeans when they
came in like the 15 hundreds,
they would tell these incredible stories
about these huge civilizations in the
Amazon. But then when explorers
came back 200 years later,
there was nothing there. And they were
like, this is crazy. They, they lied.
They must allied.
But it turns out they didn't lie.
What happened was smallpox ran through
the fucking jungle and white people,
everybody, we did it. And then these,
the jungle just overtook the cities and
now they're finding these cities with
something called Lidar.
They use these planes and they circle
over this area or helicopters or whatever
the fuck they do.
And they shoot this shit down this lidar.
It's like laser radar and it gives you
a detailed image of what's below the
surface and what's their shit. And it
shows them all these crazy structures,
all these like,
uh,
like roadways and irrigation systems
and circles inside of a square.
Like it was villages and cities and the
millions of people probably live there.
Look at it. That's all the stuff
they're finding that, yeah.
And all of it was
swallowed up by the jungle.
They think within like a hundred
years just vanished in the jungle. Oh,
because it's so, so lush and
tropical down there. Dude,
it was one of the most amazing podcast
I've ever done to listening to that guy.
Tell this story right after this
one though. Now you are the best.
You're the best. This is kind of, well,
this is like a, this is like the findings
of Atlantis, right? Like
when they started finding,
you started finding more and
more land under Christine, this,
they found traces of five drugs including
dimethyltryptamine on a thousand year
old South American ritual, key empty
baby. That's like proof positive,
um,
evidence that it at least 1000
years ago they were using Iowasca.
Wow. This was the drug pouch
that was made from Fox snouts.
That's so crazy. It
literally, when you see it,
it looks like they used
everything and the first crazy,
it looks really nice and knows.
I wonder why they do that with a Fox.
It's probably like some
cleverness something though
that that's what a showman,
that's like literally what
a shaman is supposed to.
That's what the definition is
supposed to be in certain cultures,
certain cultures. It's a clever fellow.
That's who the sh the shaman is. Okay.
I kind of make sense.
They are just clever fellows,
but I mean imagine that like he takes
a Fox, that clever little fucker.
I'm going to take his face.
I want wanted fucking drugs in his face.
Only a person would think to do something.
So great trucks and this
chipmunk cheeks. Yeah, right.
That would be the good little,
yeah.
The little pouch sugar pouches
that hangs for your belt.
It's just chip Monck sheets with
all your coins in it. The dump.
What about the dumbest animal?
You could have stuff ed.
What would be the worst animal
to put stuff in it? Gunks skunks.
Raccoons or raccoons are
actually kind of smart, you know?
Do you know skunks are predators? This
little creeps? They are, yeah. Yeah, Bro.
They were coming from a chicken's, Oh
yeah. They try to eat your chickens.
You want to kill your chickens? They skunk
up the for this spray him and shit. No,
they're just there to kill the [inaudible]
only spray things when things come
near them. When they're or when they're
about to die. Right. That's like the,
when they think they're going to
die, they just admit that. Yeah.
That's like so many animals
are able to do that.
We're like one of the only species that
doesn't know how to fake death to have
to avoid actually dying.
Right.
A lot of species we'll hide or change
colors or shapes and we're a mid something
to give the other species, the, the, the,
the thought that they are dead or
deceased or that they've, you know,
they're gone. We don't do, we
don't, we are the only ones.
Don't know if you're
running away from a fight,
you can't just pretend to be dead
and then they'll stop fucking, you
still gonna fuck you up. Well, human
beings, well I think humans and chimps to,
they want retribution. He want
revenge. We love vengeance, man.
That's like our favorite
thing in the world.
A guy almost fucking hit me four times
today. I wish I got his license plate.
I called them out on here and he was
cutting me off and he kept trying to hit
like hit my car after he cut me off in
a big like f three 50 truck and then I
gave him one of these fucking Hawk like,
dude, I mean just miss my car, you know?
Then I move on.
Well he pulls over next to me,
gives me the finger and then tries to like
pulling my fucking lane like he's, he,
if he's going to hit my car out
of his, I was like, it's okay.
He just knows.
He just knows his car hits my car.
His car has barely any damage on it.
He knows a big f three 50 trucks.
His tires the size of my fucking car.
He was a dick, but he wanted shit.
So it's like now vindictively I
hope I see him again. Like now,
just want to fucking see him again
somewhere in the city. Just started.
Just this guy. I want to have
that moment with them again.
See Him outside of his fucking big truck.
That's funny. Yeah, we love, we like I,
I don't hold grudges.
Like Bobby Lee and I were talking about a,
Bobby holds the biggest grudges on earth.
He some of the worst.
I mean he has like 20 year
grudges. Really? Oh my God.
Bobby Lee ask him about it.
He genuinely,
when someone does the wrong thing to him,
like I'm not talking
like makes a bad mistake.
When someone does something where
you're like, that's fucked up,
that can fuck up a friendship.
He will hold that against you for the
rest of time. That's it. That's it.
Where some people would go, whatever, man,
I forgive you. Shit happens. Nah, he's,
he holds a fucking grudge, dude.
Bad. That little tiny ball.
Rice ball has a lot of fucking vengeance
inside of him. He's my little dump.
How dare you? I'm allowed to say that,
man. I'm allowed to say that because I uh,
because I used to own Bobbie. I
used to buy, bought him for a month.
How much did it cost? 65 grand.
That's a lot. Did you anything, any,
did you have to feed him?
He doesn't really require that much food.
Now when does he get to own you?
That's part of the deal, right?
He owns you for a month. 10
years later. 10 years later.
He owns you for a whole model
with me for a month. Yeah.
Then he's going to be stewing on it for
10 years. People really did do that.
If they just decide, okay, you
can own me for one month. Yeah,
and I'll do whatever the fuck you want,
but then I own you for one month.
10 years from now. That's a great
movie. By the way. This is a crazy deal.
It's [inaudible] alive.
Meanwhile, like nine years later,
that dude's just drank in and chain smoke
and try to kill him to kill us because
it was a flood of figures
slave for a month.
That'd be like indentured servitude,
right.
Mostly was people that were too poor
to make journeys are too poor to do
something.
So they would give up a certain amount
of like they would make a contract,
like they would work for someone
for a certain amount of time. Right.
That's essentially how we set up.
Yeah.
I mean that's basically what it is
basically saying like, but it's, yeah. Is,
it's like a slut. I mean, I guess the
condition is probably varied. You know,
one of the grossest ones
I ever saw was, um, uh,
vice did a piece about Dubai,
I believe it was, and about,
um, some people who are unscrupulous, uh,
construction people would take these
folks in from Third World countries and
promised them all this
money to work there.
And then they'd take their passports away
from them and then pay them a fraction
of what they're supposed to pay for
them so that they're trap and they were
living in squalor, trapped. They
don't have their passport anymore.
Human trafficking is what it is.
I mean,
that's the same as when they
do to these young girls.
They had these girls come over to
the United States, you know, uh,
I think it was a documentary on Netflix
about these, like young Russian models,
right? And they give these goals modeling
contracts. They live in, uh, you know,
like a four bedroom apartment, two girls
to a room, right. And they essentially,
you know, fuck them around for a
little while with small little weird,
maybe random gigs. And they're like,
hey, if you want to make more money,
you could always sell your
body or sell pictures of you.
Nude makes way more money and they
think it's kind of part of this modeling
thing, and this is like a content. I think
it was a d, I think it was on Netflix,
but it was all about these girls
getting trapped and they can't go back.
They don't have enough money. And this,
this modeling agencies, modeling agencies,
these are these manager,
manager agencies there.
Well we have to keep your money and we'll
give you like a a salary so to speak.
We pay your rent, we'll give
you food. It's horrible. But
if it was dudes, I wouldn't care
at all. Yeah, of course. Of course.
It was true.
It was these five handsome guys came over
from Russia looking to get some pussy
and drive Ferrari's,
but it wasn't really working out for them.
But like get a job, get a
job. It's switching gears.
Where the fuck did you
think was going to happen?
You're just going to get
pussy and Ferrari. Get outta
here bro. I'm good looking.
I thought this would make me make me say
I'm sorry I can't get you any modeling
gigs, but if you want to make some
money, fuck this old lady. Sup.
How much for two grand for me to fuck
that old lady. Okay, so all you gotta do.
Do I have to come or just hang with
her for awhile? She has to. She asked.
I have to work with Hotel Chicago.
Yeah. So you got to work with her. Okay.
You got to be a good act. No
eating pussy. I can't do that. Oh,
you have to do to proceed.
I have two, three grand.
They don't even shave old
ladies. They gave up. Okay,
so eat Harry Bush for two grand. I'll
do three grand. Three grand. [inaudible]
right.
How much sympathy would you have for
their watch to show Gigolos on showtime?
I didn't, but I know shop watched it.
I know Tom and Christina loved it.
They talked about it a lot. Why is it
that shop right there on the right,
so they stick it ran its course.
It was on for like seven. No,
it was not up for 60 g's.
Interviewed one of the guys that belief,
by the way,
every TV show I've done is only gone for
like two years, but Gigolos gets six.
That's the state of television. Jesus
Christ. That is crazy. That's a very,
that's a very good tell by the way.
There's like not a lot of these, these uh,
this whole like the culture of male
Gigolos I think they said percentage wise
it's like unbelievably smaller.
These guys that get into the Gigolo world
and stay, they all get, they get in,
they get out.
Most women that get into sex work,
La last significantly
longer than these dudes way,
way long for very varied reasons.
But I think the Gigolo thing is kind of
like a moment in a man's life where he's
like, I want to fucking try it some
young like fun, loving free for all.
It's like open mind. I'll just give
it a world and he gets right out.
I don't think that happens for girls
at all. I think women stay in second.
Would you feel bad for some dude who
was working as a Gigolo in his pimp was
shook night and it's pimp
was making them go out there,
eat that pussy now to make that money.
It's the website for it.
I just know on a website for it.
Yeah.
That's actually writes really
good poets or this guy.
What's going on within Vin Armani?
What's going on when he works
at the coffee shop around
the corner from my house.
Why is he wearing in Charlotte? Thought
that's just how it says. Look Dude,
Bradley, Lawrence, Nicole.
Hey man, I ain't hating.
If you could sling Dick and get paid,
good luck to you. Look, some people do it.
Some people out there working as a misuse
that do not like touching people. Okay.
Tell me how much that is. That's a bummer
though. How much different is that then?
Being able to be a guy on wear.
Nice shirts like that and
occasionally got a bank broad.
You don't want to wear nice
shirts, so horrible. Look,
you get some nice now. Fuck.
The world could be worse.
Do you remember Richard Gere?
Wasn't he a Gigolo in one of his movies?
Who is,
he didn't have a movie called Gigolo.
We'd like bang old ladies.
I don't know if it's called Gigolo,
but yeah,
he think it was called Gigolo
Gigolo. That's right. Boy,
you must have loved this shit. Yeah. You
know, she gives up their bag and ladies,
here's what they don't tell you.
Most of that money and that Gigolo
world is sucking Dick. Okay.
If you want to go out there and suck
that Dick, you can make that money.
But if you just want to bang old ladies,
ah, Whoa, look at the difference.
That's when he was young. That's when he
was how old you gotta be like 22, 23. Um,
he was pretty young and handsome and then
father Tom done fucking Molly wop him
all the time. Got Him. Marvin
Hagler on Thomas Hearns
third round.
I remember when he went on
stage in New York after nine 11.
Who did Richard Gere did and,
uh,
was trying to tell the audience that
they should choose love and that,
wait,
we're not state state where on stage she,
he was on stage at some sort of a
benefit. Oh, right. After nine 11.
It was right after nine 11. And he
was saying essentially that, you know,
great message.
She was,
at the time people were just blood
thirsty and they booed him. They're like,
fuck you. What are you saying? Fuck you.
He's basically saying let's
not have military action.
More people shouldn't die because of
some things that these people did to us.
He's saying try to figure out a different
way to do this. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, he's,
he's, he's a Buddhist I believe.
I mean, he's really like,
he's really close pals with
the Dalai Lama. Yeah. But, but,
but in the interest of talking
about what we're talking about,
revenge means a lot.
It's Kinda hard to tell America to
not get revenge on somebody. Right.
We love revenge. Well, yeah. Well,
we love getting back people that have
tried to fuck with us. Even if we go,
even if we go way deeper than they did
were warlike monkeys. Yeah, we love it.
We we,
we when,
when we think we're being attacked
like retribution and revenge is,
well we're just talking about earlier
about like chimps. Chimps do that too.
Natural, it's nature, nature,
nature. You want to get revenge.
Motherfuckers like we were talking about
that guy and got ripped apart by the
chimp rent to bring a birthday cake.
Dude.
See other chimps that did it
because they were jealous.
They were angry that that jealous
of getting this compassion.
You didn't get shit and someone fucked
up and left the gate open and they came
out.
Fuck that dude up.
He ripped his limbs off toward his face
part just because he wouldn't give them,
didn't bring cake for them where
they female chimps now there a man,
where's my cake losing it?
Cake must be so must've been good ass
fucking cake to a chimp that doesn't
understand what cake is like.
Hold the fuck dude, you do this.
But they do understand what cake is.
Wherever they understand it.
Once you get it to them, the gem.
Yeah. It's something, it's, it's,
that's like a powerful or be brought.
That's how you want more in Costa Rica.
And uh, there's, there's monkeys
everywhere. That's crazy.
Cool. Cool. Last monkeys,
but there are a little sketchy. I know.
I got married down there and oh, he did.
And Costa Rica. Yeah. Yeah. They're
out. They're out of their fucking mind.
We were hanging out with them and uh,
there's a thing called a [inaudible]
Monday. You know what that is? No,
they look like a,
like a raccoon monkey thing
to weird creature, a rocky.
And uh,
they would come up,
we were staying at this resort and they
would just come right down the pathway
to where your, uh, your door to your room
was and they'd just hang out with you.
Like these Quad Mondays just hang out
and you could feed them grapes and shed.
They would take them right out of your
hands, but it like no danger at all.
They were like super chill and friendly.
So we gave this quantum
Monday some grapes,
and then he laid down and took a nap
under my chair. I just took a fucking nap,
like a dog was a dog and like the most
chill dog of all time. I'm like, God damn,
these things are cool. Like we were
just sitting there. It just check, oh,
go ahead buddy. Tickets,
take a nap. You're safe here
again. Some grapes and shit.
People want it. Want chimps at their
house. People love the idea of,
of having them. So the monkeys came over
and we only had a, that's what a quad,
a Monday. It looks like, dude,
they're the shit. There's,
there's such cool little animals.
It does kind of look raccoon ish.
My daughters gave him a fake name, like
a, they were calling him a Kinkajou.
They just decided to call it a
Kinkajou. What's more fun? Yeah,
they could choose made their own word up,
I think.
I don't think that's a real word.
Kalata Monday,
but that little that'll guy was so cool.
So she's an interesting little fella
when you just would gently take grapes
right out of your hand gently,
right the most chill dog of all time.
So anyway, we were out of grapes and
these a monkey showed up and they're,
they're like hanging out, like
looking like, what do you got for us?
These guys are hungry.
No real monkey that's on a monkey.
I don't know what that is.
I don't know what a cold water Monday is.
What family is, what is that?
Anyway, we gave these, uh, my killer,
like I don't know if we should
give these monkeys, these Oreos.
It's Kinda fucked up. Like it's not
good for them. I'm going to look at,
one of them only had one hand. I'm like,
well that's not good for him either.
The fucking handbid off. So
I gave him, gave him that,
he snatched it from me and he opened it
up and then started chewing the white
stuff like the cream. He's one of us, but
he already knew about it, knew to like,
he's probably getting Oreos for his whole
life time from people that stay at the
resort. He knows the trek. Did he? I mean
he knew what the fuck to do. I'll do it.
Well they make you at this, you
know, they're all open air houses.
You rent on the beach,
you know that everything's pretty open
except for the bedroom is the only thing
that's closed off.
And they had latched locks,
padlocks on the refrigerator. And I was
like, what are you guys lock that up?
And they're like, the monkeys know
how to get into all that shit.
They know how to open the door and they
know how to get into drawers. He's like,
dude, they knew how to, they
know how to open up egg cartons.
They know how to open the lid and take
eggs and close the lid. I'm not kidding.
He's like, they're that smart.
So in the middle of the night,
the first night that we were there,
I hear the gate kind of rustling and
then I hear movement and I'm like,
someone's in the fucking house cause
it's on the beach. It's wide open.
So of course I like grabbed something
is the biggest thing I could find.
Nice man. I'm out there. I'm
like, Hey, hey, you know,
like a nut bag and my fucking arm,
um, yelling. Of course I look it,
they're just monkeys. Chillen trying
to like get shit in the house.
They're trying to find shit laying
around food, drinks, whatever it was.
And of course I go back to bed and every
night I would hear them come and go,
but you'd hear them try the refrigerator.
They would hear him pulling on
it to see if the latch was like,
if we left it unlocked. They're
smart, they learn, they learn,
they learn all the little tricks
of where you put stuff. Cabinets.
I could hear a cabinet is opening and
closing. Yeah, they were smart man.
That's so weird. It's like a little
person. It is a little sneaky,
but yet it was a little person.
He fuck use it. And they,
and they put purposely up in
this place that I was at, um,
they'd purposely string wire
from house to house to house.
So the monkeys kind of had freedom to go
up above because if they would go down
by the road, it would cause more traffic
and disturbances and all that stuff.
So they keep them up in the canopy.
They put rope purposely house to house
and tree to tree that humans put up.
So they have easier pathways to get
down to the water because they say when
they're down on the ground, it's
more distracting. There's, you know,
it's a lot harder to drive. They,
they create little messes down below.
So if they keep them up high, it's
better for them. It was crazy man.
What a wild little creature that can swing
from tree to tree and they fly up and
down the tree tops like that.
There is a guy from shit,
just one most like people
sometimes I'd see one just hanging.
It'd be staring right at you, but
they're almost like people. They're so,
they're the right fucking there. Well
the weird, the weirdest thing is that if,
if evolution is happening all the time,
looking at this little monkey junk,
is this in breaking into a house? Yeah.
Watch, watch this. Watch how smart. Look,
he'll give me those chips. I love
these fucking chips. I love that.
It looks like he's looking right at
the person too. Yeah, he is. Oh Wow.
And he just takes off with the chips.
Do they know which ones they eat them?
They know which ones they like.
Just be nice to them.
What happens if you feed them?
You can't know.
They tell you not to feed them because
well then they know to keep coming back
and where they can get food for like
monkeys now they say at the end of you and
they say, if you don't, if you
swing, you stop feeding them.
After you fed them enough,
then they start to get aggressive.
So then you shoot one and he said,
tell him, send a message. Right?
And then they all come back and kill
you out of fucking 12 gauge and you blow
the little face off one of those clients
and you make your drug and you go, hey,
you guys want free food. You'll get
it. But you get it on my terms. Mcgee,
go back inside. You just described
a plot for a planet of the apes.
It's literally like the plot for
planning. You get them hooked. Yeah.
You Bait that I'm hooked on
food. Yeah. You Bait them.
There's a lot of places
like that. Um, we're, we're,
animals are dependent on people.
They were dependent on people to feed
them and it's a, it's a little squirrely.
Like whoa.
There's a place in,
I think it's Jamaica where
people swim with wild pigs. No,
Wild
Bahamas,
Bahamas.
Now wild pigs generally avoid people they
don't want to have anything to do with
you and they're dangerous. Sketchy.
Yeah. Wild boars are nuts. Yeah.
But in this place, people have been
feeding these things for so long.
They have trips like tourist
trips where people fly in,
feed these pigs and swim around with them.
Pig Island,
they got wild pigs that are
constantly being fed by people.
But a friend of a friend went there
and someone they were with got bit.
Oh yeah, I've heard they put them
in the ass a bit. One of the,
one of the pigs bit them in the ass.
And it was because they didn't have
any food or something like that.
They didn't offer him anything.
He have to keep feeding them
throughout the whole thing.
It tells you all about it that they,
that they get really ornery and they
get really annoyed. Fuck you. Fuck you.
Fuck you just drown it. Just put it right
under non bro. Those they're strong now.
They are. You can't fuck with
those sentences. The animal,
because they're beautiful and they're
sweet and the like pigs are there are
weird one and it was there. Look
as cool. Look, I'm a dog lover.
I love dogs.
Pigs are almost like a dog and
maybe smarter close their Pr.
The probably definitely smarter,
but they liked the way that we
react to people and it, look,
if you feed them and you're their friend,
you become their buddy,
but are you against eating them?
No, but also looks I've killed them.
I know that kills wild ones,
but wild ones are different men because
they're out there hustling. Okay.
They don't,
they're not in this fucking pen getting
slop all day trying to fatten them up.
Right. It's hard to get fat
out there. They're out there.
How much more lean meat out there.
They're much leaner,
but they're also vicious man.
They're v the getting rid
to grow these giant tusks,
they have these big fucking fangs.
And the crazy thing is there's the
same species as a domestic pig, right?
It's the same animal.
Just once one's one's pampered
and one's not exactly bring up.
Have you ever seen Havoline Aleena's do
you know what [inaudible] are in Arizona?
Peccary well, when I saw that
it looks just like a pig. Yeah,
that was when I first, when I first moved
to Arizona, I saw one and I was like, oh,
what the fuck is that thing? And my buddy
was like, no, no, no, don't cut it. They,
they'll come right at yet.
They will fucking go for your legs bad
because they're real low to the ground.
But he's like, they'll start spearing
you and they'll come at your legs.
And one time I was valeting in college
and when I was up way in the up in the
mountain and it's some dudes, you know,
some private, huge private residence.
And there with packs,
I mean packs of them and I could hear
them rustling around and they were like
positioning themselves because I was,
we were parking cars where they
were living and I was like,
we can't park cars up there.
You can tell they started
to get aggressive in jumping
and diving at the cars.
Yeah, they were getting fucking
annoyed, man. They didn't. I was like,
we can't go back up there.
We're going to get fucked up by these
little bullshit pigs. You don't,
we're Stan hope lives out in Bisbee,
which is real close to the border.
They have them all over the
place. Yeah, they're everywhere.
They killed one of his friend's dog.
They do kill dog. They, well they,
they're known to kill cats more,
but yeah,
they do kill dogs because dogs are about,
depending on the size of your dog,
there's some of those,
some dogs could fuck those things up
because they're not that big, but they,
they're known as murder cats.
It was a small dog, I think.
And I think they flanked it and it just
came at it from the sides of the part,
the real part of dog.
What do you do when someone,
something like that kills your dog?
Are you out with a shotgun?
Trying to find the rest of them did.
I was trying to kill coyotes after the
eight my chickens and I don't give,
I mean, I love chickens.
Like they're cute. They're my
friends. But when they died,
a couple of them died of natural causes.
Yeah. I'd be like, Aww, poor little guy.
But if my dog died, it'd be
really sad. You know what I mean?
It's a different relationship.
Different.
So when these coyotes killed my chickens,
I sat out there on the porch with a bow
and a range finder waiting to fuck them
up for days. I even tied one of the
dead chickens that they killed to a pot,
like a, you know, that you would
plant in. What are you doing, Jamie?
Um,
the Po that you plant things in.
And I sat it in the middle of the yard as
bait. Right. And I sat up there waiting.
David, one of them came and my daughter
screamed out a coyote and I'm like,
God damn, I got to teach her how to hunt.
Like I had that motherfucker that's,
it was inside of these inside of 40 yards
and he was creeping in. I was like, aw.
I had to do is get to my spot and I
would have probably got a shot. Yeah.
How 40 yards.
That's a far away [inaudible] he was
at 40 yards when my daughter scream.
Oh Shit. Well then, then
he's like, fuck this.
I stayed up there for a few hours longer.
What's the,
what's the furthest that you can feel
comfortable hitting a target for where the
little target,
you know,
there's a difference between
something that's the size of a coyote.
Coyote is only like,
they're not paying,
their body might be like a foot, a foot
and a half. They're not big at all.
Yeah. They're tiny from top to
bottom. So what we're trying to,
if you're trying to hit them in the
vitals, you don't have a lot to aim at.
It's a very small bag. Dot. Yeah. Yeah.
Want to be, you'd want to be fairly close.
I think about that all the time. They'll
go with a rifle, you could shoot them.
That's not something totally different.
I tried to kill him.
I only grew up shooting rifles.
I never shot a gun until I
was in my twenties but rifles,
I was so used to shooting.
I got so accustomed to shooting it and
then I tried to boat once and that was
unbelievably fucking hard. You
should learn. It'd be fun for it.
You can always come here and practice.
I'll come next time.
John Dudley comes into town, I'll have
him a hook you up and they'd love it, man.
Not even like to go hunting but just
to shoot targets. It's really fun.
And that like guns though. That
game out there. I do too. Yeah.
That game out there that I have that uh,
techno hunt gay dude.
Once you get into that and start playing
that once your [inaudible] at a screen,
you're fucking good at it. Oh, fun. I had
Corey Anderson, UFC light heavyweight.
He's a bow hunter.
I had him here the other day and
he was playing it cause he good.
He's really good. But you could
tell like writing me, he practiced.
He so fucking elite athlete of course
he's going to be good at, but one thing.
Yeah, that's true. What do they not,
so he's got this discipline mindset
and you know, it's just on the ball.
But um, you could say right away when
you planned, it was like, oh my God,
this is so addictive. I'm like, this
is the most addictive game of all time.
Once you started, it's hard to get let it
go. If you're an actual bow hunter, you,
you only get to shoot a thing
like a couple of times a year.
Yeah. You know, if you're going a lot,
if you're going a lot like the idea that
you're going to shoot a lot of like tea,
if you're some Ramey warrant type
character or Cameron Hanes, yeah.
You'll shoot a bunch of deer a
year and you live off those. Yeah.
But if you're a regular person,
like you think how many deer
you think you're going to find,
how many deer you think you gonna sneak
up on if you're lucky, one or two a year.
So like the moment when it happens, it's
such a big moment. You're like, fuck,
here it is. Here it is. We're
trying to stay calm and stay calm.
But with that thing you're shooting
at them all the time. Just fun.
So it's in your head.
So like what I'm seeing is this animal
moves and moves into the pocket, boom,
the release pop and it hits it perfect
and you see it over and over and over and
over and over again.
So what you learned from martial arts
and what you learned from standup,
it's the same thing that applies
to bow hunt. It's about repetition.
The more you can do it and the more you
see it over and over and over again,
the more that pattern becomes your mind.
So that gate for it,
for a guy like Cory or someone like me,
you bow hunts that games like, Holy Shit,
this is what I've been looking for. See
a real animal walk into range that would,
cause you always want to be ethical,
right?
You want to be able to
shoot the right animal.
Like you want to be able to
hit it exactly where you want,
where it expires very quickly.
The best way to do that as
well as some difference.
So this game is just super addictive.
What's it called? What's the game called?
It's called Techno Hunt Techno. Ah,
can you, your score against each other.
So if you and I were playing it like
you give 10 points for a Bullseye,
eight points for the vitals,
you get like five points for headshots.
Where's the shot? No, no.
It would have to be a very small
subset about headshots learning,
like playing gun games, first person
shooter games. Over the years,
headshots are always the most
rewarding thing. Like, oh, add shot.
But you don't want to
do that with an animal.
Do you do if you have a rifle and you
want it to die instantaneous. And it is a,
the way they do it that some hunters that
are chefs do it when they like hunters
who are chefs. Um, there's, there's
two different kinds of hunters, right?
There's a hunter's that eat the
meat and they, but they want,
they want to shoot a mature animal
because that's what everybody strives for.
It like if you're a skilled hunter,
like of your,
a Steven Rinella or someone like that,
what you're trying to get is, uh,
an old wise animal.
It's already spread its DNA and it's
mature and it's probably the end of its
breeding cycle. That's what a
guy like that wants. What he's,
he's like the ultimate hunter,
right?
What he wants is the most fair chase.
He's never hunts in high fence operations,
the most fair chase,
the wildest animal, and he wants
to get the oldest maturest one.
But then there's chefs and
chefs believe some of them do.
It's very debatable that the younger
animals tastes better than the older
animals. So they're not trying
to get an old mature animal.
They're trying to get a, a young, um,
a tender animal that isn't
like fully muscled, ripe,
worn out with a, you want some, you
want some stills tenderness to it,
some softness to the muscle. But then
there's people like Hank Shaw who's a,
also a world famous chef
who's also a hunter who prefers older
animals cause he thinks there's like
there's flavor to them and there's
life to them like that they're,
they're aging and they'll
all their life experience,
it comes out if you cook them correctly,
it just requires a different sort of
preparation. Right. It's Kinda like,
it's Kinda like a young
women versus older women.
Like young women have a lot
of positives about them,
but older women have just as
many positives about them.
Older women that flavor.
That's what you want, right? You
want to check who's like, yeah,
who didn't give a six plus who hits
the gym every day. I know. Trust me,
I know. I, I've had this conversation
about the whole night because when,
if we stop working out, it's over. I
said, if we stop working for like we,
if we stop exercising and carrying water
health, it's all there. It's over fact.
No, I mean like I wanted
a sign I wanted my, uh,
and one of my lawyer has a joke to sign
document that says if we, if we get fat,
it's like a free and clear
gone. But I mean it, if she
gets fat out, if I get fat,
she should be out. If either of us break
this thing that we're doing together,
what if it brings you closer that we get,
she gets fed to worry about body image
anymore. Fuck you just let yourself go.
Fuck that. Come on. Fuck
that shit. Hey, hey,
hey shaming right now. We can realize it
or not. Hey, I know you don't want sham
show you fat. Fuck, I can't
believe you. I just think,
I think we've made a bond together.
We made a pact where we're like,
we both want to stay relatively
healthy and take care of ourselves.
So in our older years,
like my parents are both in,
in really great shape because
they've cared their whole lives.
Not to a point of like,
you know, not having fun,
they still have a great fucking time,
but just they just stayed consistent
with a caring about what you put in your
body and the way you work as simple
shit. So yeah, if she gets fat by,
if I get that she's by two, if I get
fucking fat, she's gone. She even said it.
She was like,
I'll leave your fat ass being fat.
It's such a weird one that people
call people fat who aren't fat. Right?
I mean it might be,
but I'm just saying like as an insult.
It's such a weird one. It is because
like girls will call girls fat.
Like that fat bitch look at our is not
fat. No. What he's saying, it's just that,
let's just say it's a dig. It's
another gift for you. You Fat.
Fuck the guys who say that. The guys that
like barely have any fat on bed. Fuck,
we need to know the cheeseburger.
Jamie. You Fat. Fuck. Fuck that it,
it's an easy day. It's an easy insult to,
to how to grow. Call me fat at the con.
There's a video of it online.
Who girl calling me fat at the comedy
store and a pull up my sheet, my six pack.
No, like long time now.
Crazy. But it was like,
why am I am I'm fat?
Like what?
Where are you coming up with
that you're affecting you're fat.
I bet you it's a weird thing.
The the,
the fact that the body
can carry excess tissue.
It's a mistake. Like I get it.
It's a good way to store fuel.
And when it gets to a point
like why are you still hungry?
What kind of shitty system do we have
that you're this big and you're still
hungry? Didn't attempt to break and
say, hey bro, bro, bro, Bro, stop.
We got the fuel.
But it does not put to your bodies
and working off carbohydrates.
That's a problem. Right?
And it's not burning fat.
That's why that whole ketogenic diet works
as much as people don't like to think
that it does. There's so much controversy
about that, like from nonscientists,
which is hilarious.
Have you talked to actual scientists like
Dom D'agostino who talked to you about
the peer reviewed research?
That's been done on ketogenic states and
all the different benefits and what you
know and how it could be healthy and
how he does it and Ketone esters and all
these different factors you have to take
into consideration and they'd ketone
testing and blood testing it.
There's all these knuckleheads saying
it's bad for you. It's not a good idea.
Like Julian Micheal. It's like it's
not a good idea. It's not good.
You finished up, they say
that as a benefit. Sam Pounds,
right. It's a normal state.
It's a normal state for your body to
burn fat and you have more clarity and
you'll also, you're not as hungry. You're
not as hungry during the day. My team,
my problem with it is I don't think
it's the best thing for performance.
I think like you have a
little bit more energy if he,
you burn glucose too cause
even like the top, ah,
there's a Zack bitter.
He wouldn't even when the American,
he ran 20 he ran a hundred miles
in like 11 hours around a track.
These guys that could do this shit.
It was some crazy record.
Two miles and I need to chill
for a minute. Some crazy,
some crazy record for a hundred
mile record. He broke 11 hours,
40 minutes second. That's
insane. That a minute mile,
seven minute miles or a
hundred fucking miles.
Now he is on primarily a carnivore diet.
All meat, all meat, rib eyes, and
barely eat barely any meat and fat.
Barely any greens. Right? Barely in
Greens. But then when he competes,
he takes a lot of uh, glucose.
Like he'll take like glucose gel,
like those gels. Gel packets. Yes.
And those runners use, yeah, he,
he pounds in that shit. Pounds
in the carbs. So he could
burn that off too. Right.
You know, cause he's living
off for like fat and protein.
But when he competes, he
doesn't do that. And the thing,
I think that's the key. You're saying
when he competes, he does use the glucose,
but when he's done competing he does.
He goes back to putting his body in a fat,
a fat burning state.
It's a pure carnivore.
Our diets are kind of crazy
as I don't like pure, just,
just meat and nothing else. And
saw the eight man. I know you,
Jordan Peterson has done it now for over
a year and he released his blood work
or the results of his blood work.
At least everything's in range.
Everything's healthy.
Supplemental vitamins, nothing.
No, he doesn't do anything.
He eats steak with salt
on it and he drinks water.
And I'm telling you, listen to me, man.
If he gets a Perrier with lime in it,
he'll spit it out.
He doesn't want the lime in a fucking
Perry and that it's yes. Crazy.
That's too much. I lost 50
pounds, 50 pounds, 80 pounds,
lost 50 pounds. He had some
serious immunological, uh, issues.
Um, immunological that'll
word and know. Yeah,
it sounds made up. Yeah. I Dunno.
He had serious immune deficiency.
He had immunity, immune deficiency.
Immunological Bob. But doesn't it sound,
it sounds phony. Yeah. It sounds fake.
Immunology and immunology, you know,
but immunological sounds blood bullshit.
It sounds like you took two
words and put them together.
Where fake sophistication,
sophistication,
he'd some serious issues, um, as helped.
Yeah, dude also suffered from depression.
All that stuff.
Look,
a lot of what they think that a lot
of the issues that people suffer from,
they suffer because of inflammation.
And when scientists are studying things
at the carnivore diet, what would,
what's striking to them almost more than
the fact that you're just eating meat
is that you're not eating
all these other things.
And so that in giving your body
only one food source to deal with,
sometimes your body can eliminate
a lot of the issues that it has.
And it also mimics like some of
the benefits of fasting. It's,
I'm too stupid to be really judging this.
I don't know. I'm listening to all that.
I know that I'm fucking dumped too.
He had like receding gums,
he had some serious gum
issues that all went away.
All these things went away when he was
on that carnivore diet for you. Okay.
I don't eat like that. I'm not saying
eat like I don't eat like that.
I think it's gotta be a balance,
I think.
I think some people may
may work with that, right?
But they'll also tell you there's so many
diets that people do that their blood
doesn't line up with that diet.
It's not good for them. Right.
Some people that just works
with, right. Some people,
some people can have higher intakes of
red meat and other people, it's really,
really bad for their system just
because of the way were blood is,
well some people are literally
allergic to it. Right. But like uh,
like my wife needs way more iron,
like needs like has to happen.
So whether it's supplemented by pills
or by higher incidence of meets with
higher iron in it comes a lot of vitamins
in it and some iron. I'm Natalie,
I can't produce any more man. None.
They cut off my balls. Doo, Doo Doo.
I turned him in. Yeah. What did it,
what caused you to turn them in?
What was the final straw?
Was this movement downtown La
Barista at your own gender? Yeah.
I went to the me too thing and I cut
off my balls and I left him there.
So I just, I donated them if you like,
if people started calling for that.
If girls are calling for that,
guys would do it. Remove your nuts.
There's guys out there that would,
there is a certain kind of guy that would,
there's so many people there.
If you called for guys to step out into
the middle of the town square and cut
their own balls off,
at least a couple of guys would show up.
I can name two to send us.
We live in,
there's a couple of dudes I know
that would fuck up that exactly.
Just for like Twitter credit.
Yeah, just for some street. I just,
I just rather read tweets.
Love from is how you are an ally.
Boys learn like my fed. Like we were
favorite. Like your favorite shirts.
Yeah. Females kick ass or what is it? Oh
women kick ass or whatever else. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. That'll hold
the idea of like a of a,
of virtue signaling overt,
overt support for
something. It's so seethrough when
you're like, I'm here for you girls.
It's so seethrough. God, it's
such a crock of shit, but the,
they can feel that way without
yelling at all the time we pull.
You also like broadcasting like that.
Like what? What are you doing? Yeah.
What are you doing? What's the
purpose? Yeah, that's what I like. Why?
Why are you reaching out? You're
supporting, what do you supporting?
What is happening here?
It's another instance of the echo chamber
doing the whole supporting the thing
that I don't think people are really,
I talk about it on stage
about the Trent Trent,
the word transphobic over
like I understand the meaning,
but I also think it's hyperbolized and
in essence of like there are these large
groups of people that are against trans
people. I don't believe that whatsoever,
but there were definitely are.
I think there's small groups of
people that get a lot of attention.
I don't think there's massive look. The
KKK is significantly larger of a group.
Then whatever group you want to formulate
of a transfer of trans phobic nature.
I know a lot of people don't
even know what that is. Right?
I haven't done any statistical research.
Look how many KKK members
are in the United States?
There are tens of thousands.
Okay. How many people? What do people do?
I think a trans people religious that,
that don't believe in trans people or
they don't think that they should be able
to call themselves a woman.
I think Ma,
I think most of those people don't care
enough to call themselves part of that
category. They just disagree with they go,
I don't really like it. I don't get it.
I think,
I think there's more of those than
there are people that are like adamantly
against trans rights.
I think we have to take into consideration
what we already said about God's
willing to cut their balls off that
there are guys like that or sure.
There are some,
there are so many people in this country.
I guarantee you there's a lot of trans
phobic people a lot. Cause listen man,
if you read the comments and I don't,
and I didn't,
but someone told me that the
comments and the Eddie Izzard uh,
Instagram posts that
are made were horrific.
But don't you think that
is an internet fodder?
See that's my thing is I think people
like to say shit on the Internet,
even if they don't believe it, because
they know that gets attention. If they go,
fuck this fucking dude looks like a
chick that I don't know what they said.
Maybe they were just making fun
of the way he looks. So you can,
you can assume what fucking people right
on the Internet about that, that issue.
They would just go, what's up with this?
Fuck. Oh, here. I'll give you an example.
I tweeted the other day about
the met gala Harry styles. Uh,
I tweeted a,
uh,
he was wearing like a lot of men were
wearing like dresses at the met gala.
This was a whole thing.
And I tweeted,
Tilda Swinton looked fire at the met
gala because he looked like Tilda Swinton
not cause I'm saying like,
who's till the swim?
She's a fucking actress who has short
hair, right. So right. That was him.
And I said, Tilda Swinton looked fire
at the met gala. Who is this gentleman?
He's a, he's a pop star. He's like part
of, what's it called? One direction.
He's part of one direction. What?
What is happening with that shirt?
That's what he wore to the met. Callous.
What'd you say Jamie? It's a blouse.
Blouse. Shirts versus blouses.
Okay. Here's the thing.
If you're going to one of those things
and you're going to stand in front of all
these jackasses with cameras taking
pictures of why not wear a fucking blouse?
That's what, that's what, but I said till
the sweat and looked fire because
when I saw the first image,
his face kind of looked
like Tilda Swinton. Okay.
Of course I'm making the joke about a
joke. You're a comedian. Well, dude,
everyone was like very funny
last night. Thank you. Thank you.
Everyone went after me. Everyone
was like, oh, of course you fucking,
I mean Habsi are you a Nazi? The,
here's my problem. They go, um, he,
I think he's gay, right? Is
He, is he gay? Jamie? No,
I think somebody told me they were
like alone. They were like your, your,
your menu. I was like, Whoa, I can't
make fun of people anymore for people.
I said he looked like till the fucking
Swinton. Why are you reading comments?
Because I'm not as famous as you stop
and think about the amount of people that
have had their balls.
I know that would just walk into that
town square and cut their balls off.
Now stop and think about those
people commenting. Yeah, I know.
And you're reading it and allowing
it to fuck with your head.
Sometimes I feed into it. A lot
of times I don't. When do you not?
When I'm confident in whatever I
posted. That's interesting. Right?
We're not like that joke.
I knew it was going to be misinterpreted.
Like I knew when I wrote that I go, some
of them misinterpret this. Who Care?
That's why I still posted it, but, but
I read some shit sometimes if I go,
I wonder if that was
dumb or if that was cool.
Wouldn't it be fun if you could be half
drunk all the time and never suffered
any physical consequences?
Me, you know, I'd love that.
Nothing would make me more happy. Love
drinking, but with a half a buzz on,
you know that feeling when
you got to half of on it?
Like my favorite thing in the world
because no one could touch me.
Just feel good. You know how I know that
feeling, hanging out with your friends,
having a buzz and not worried about it.
That's how alcoholism starts.
I think that was a lot of members of
my family had half a buzz all the time,
but well, half a buzz all the
time would be a, it's like a,
that'd be a good place to be. Maybe. How
many [inaudible] how many chats are good?
Half of the bad half.
You came a little little like that
feeling you get after that first glass of
wine when you're like, ah, why do
you think people have wine at lunch?
A lot of people show up work.
I sushi had someone was drinking a
bottle of wine by herself yesterday.
Is that league, like if you work
in an office and you have a glass,
did they let you have a cocktail at
lunch? Totally. It depends on who you are,
where you work. If you listened in
our industry, entertainment street,
there's no fucking rules. Well,
obviously, but I'm saying like a regular,
but do you remember the dude who used
to run the Tempe Improv didn't want you
doing shots before you go onto the note,
no drinks before you pop a conversation
with me about it. He's like,
do you really need that? And I was like,
Hey, hey, listen to me. Look at me.
I'm a professional, right? I'm also an
athlete or I work out a lot. I'll be fine.
I'll be, I'm going to do this
or I'm going to go to the gym.
You want to work out with me? Yeah,
we'll shut the fuck up, man. Come on.
Just on the club, dude. I'm not, I'm
not going to get so drunk or can't talk.
I'm having a shot. Yeah. Four I perform.
If you became one of those guys, yeah,
you would know.
Everybody knows.
It's like I know what I'm doing
and even if I have too many,
if I have four or five instead of two,
I'm going to be okay.
Like I'm growing up. I'm still figuring
it out. Driving anywhere, drug.
I'm not doing anything stupid
working tonight. In fact, there's
nights where I've had a few,
cause I've been sad about where I am,
like I'm at a club that I don't want to
be at or something and I'll have a few
too many,
but I'll get on stage and the first
thing I think is I still got to put on a
show. I still got to work hard,
but I'm a little, little drunk,
but autopilot kicks in a little bit
sometimes. Like back in the day,
if I was sad about the small shitty room,
it would just kick into the jokes I
already knew were going to work and I was
kinda going through the motions.
I was still delivering,
but it was sad because you're like,
I'm not,
I don't know if I'm enjoying this or I'm
going through the motions if I'm just
kind of like, Hey, this is the joke.
That's the joke in my mind is just
on a Rolodex of like this joke,
spend that joke where now I'm just had
a happier place in my career that now if
I do, if I did get a little
too drunk for, I want to stage,
I'd be genuinely nervous.
I'd be nervous about my performance level.
It's like fuck him. Are they going
to hear me slip up a little bit?
Am I going to cause I'll feel
it because with, with great,
with great power comes
great responsibility rate.
The greater the rooms,
the group, the bigger the rooms,
the more power, not me but with,
but the bigger the rooms get,
the more I feel more.
I feel more responsible to do even
better than I have been doing.
Do you walked out on stage in San Diego
in front of 13 13,000 people and own
that motherfucker is fucking
wild. It was wild. It felt,
you know what it was doing in the round.
It was weird to do the round.
I, I don't know if I love it.
I don't know if I loved it or hated it,
but it was this feeling of such
uniqueness that I couldn't judge it in the
moment like it was too.
It was happening so fast.
There was no, there's no sitting on
the stool and there's 13,000 people.
There's no stagnancy.
You have to keep moving.
You're moving around the whole title.
Yeah. I liked it. It's interesting.
It was wild because the screens are so
big and everybody could always see your
face no matter where. Yeah, it
was. It was good. I loved it.
13,000 human beings. It's a
lot of fucking people, son,
who's very weird by the way. I'm
going to Denver. When is that?
What does it know? Jamie's gimme
give wrong information? Jamie.
Jamie just blurts things out. Just
takes chances. 24th of September,
he's been slipping a little bit.
Have you noticed Sanchez draw?
What's been going on? Jamie? Half Trump
all the time. You have bust. It's August.
August what? 23 and 24 hours.
23rd I'm at the Belko theater.
How did you not know that?
Jamie and I just belted that out.
And then you have the fucking computer.
August 9th I'm in Portland and August
10th I'm in the bay area at the shoreline.
Amphitheatre yeah. Oh Shit.
Oh Shit. Oh Shit. Oh Shit.
And have some fun dude.
Fucking, hey, we go to Chicago.
I'm going to go with you to Chicago.
Austin. Austin was a good guy. Incredible.
Incredible. It's so good. Yeah,
it's great. Cap City, you know,
one of the best clubs in the country.
That's like it. I think doing those clubs,
like doing weekends at clubs is
real valuable. That's, I got to,
I'm going to book more of those,
you know,
it gets great always to be working at
the store and it's great when we're doing
these big places in the road,
but those clubs,
there's something about like if
you've done xannies in Nashville,
never done Sandy's Nashville, let's do it.
Zany Chicago. I've got never Nashville.
Let's do it.
Okay,
let's do it.
Let's got that pleases Shit.
You see that the punchline in San
Francisco follows and so the parlor live,
the part of their lives going down
to the punchline is closing forever.
They might move it. No, no, no. Here's
what's happening. This is the real report.
I read it.
I read a,
an article again this morning because
last night Ali Wong told me, and um,
I read the article that was posted this
morning and it basically said they lost
their lease.
They couldn't renew it because it's got,
that building's getting
bought out basically.
So they are working diligently
now to try to relocate the club.
So we just need to find a new look. Yeah.
But it, but, but for the time being,
it's going to be gone.
You know what I worry about?
I'm worried they're going to go
big like did with cops, right?
Like I used to do cobb's um,
when it was not,
I don't think it was 150 seats. It
was tiny. Right now it's like four 50.
[inaudible] it became, it became the
opposite of what you used to be. Right.
It used to be a place that you would go,
you'd make less money but you'd have
more fun cause it was like real tight.
Everybody was like smashed into this place
and it was a legendary place. That's,
that's, that's easily one of the
best and I want it to go back,
which kind of sucks that
it's going to be gone now.
The reason I love this club so much,
so what you see is the stage
and tables and behind us,
which you can't see as the
bars in the back of the room,
which is one of my favorite
elements of a cool club.
You don't need to worry about people
getting a drink to the side or the left
behind.
You can't hear an ice machine,
but it's in the very back of the room
and they do such a good job of hiding
their noise and they're distractions.
So it's all about the show.
They were fucking so good at
it, man. They're really good.
I hope they keep it intimate venue
or really do. Yeah, I love that room.
Needs an intimate venue.
Does San Francisco have a
good comedy scene these days?
I hear,
I hear a variant of stories.
I think a lot of people would say
that was better back back, you know,
a couple decades ago.
But I do think that when I go up there,
when I had been up there,
there's a lot of young people that are
really good that are coming still out in
northern California, but I mean
cobs and there used to be, um,
what is it? Green onion? No, the purple
onion. Yeah. That used to be there.
There was no, there was one
more. Is that what it's called?
Why does it sound wrong? I don't know
cause I'm saying it sounds wrong. No,
is it the purple onion look up. The
purple line is like, I think you're right.
But it sounds, it's one of those things,
yeah. Where you're like, the other thing,
we talked about it again, that
sounds wrong. You're like,
you made that a logical immunological.
I'm,
we're gonna open up a club called
immunological purple onion. But I, I,
I don't know shit about the fucking San
Francisco scene anymore because the only
clubs that I've done are,
the only things I've done are punchline
and I did cops I think Zach Galifianakis
special at live of the purple
line? Yes. That's right.
A small price to per blended. Yeah. It
was tiny, tiny sat gone. That plays,
I think that's not there anymore.
So the like for like real
intimate spots on the road,
like you still have Atlanta.
Atlanta has got one of the best places.
That's that's that's gone.
Gone Fuck 2012 yeah,
it was called to close in 2012 God,
look how intimate it is.
Small.
It is the only other venue that's like
that that's small like that still is like
you're talking about laughing skull is
still small. That's still tiny. Tiny.
What does that seat like? 90 I think
they said 90 yeah, a hundred a therapist,
a packed out stuff and I'm in there.
I went, I was in town doing something.
I went over there to watch
garland to watch Jeff to
Jeff's thing. And how was it?
It's just Jeff, Jeff, Jeff.
Jeff is so unabashedly clear that
he's just fucking around like he was.
So obviously like I'm going to fucking
do this whole set about one guy and he
picked like picked the guy in the audience
and he the entire set about the guy
and it was just like, I'm just
fucking around. He was having some,
he was having tons of fun. He's a sweet
guy. He's hilarious man. He's here,
he moves. He is, his brain moves, uh,
very fast in a way that I
wouldn't anticipate. Right.
For some reason you think I,
you're like this is he quick is that
he's very quick. He's a fucking,
he's a very cool, funny dude I like
to do, but yeah, I haven't, uh,
I don't know. I'm starting to do a
few new clubs now and in the size,
the sizing is different and I just,
I like to be able to do bigger places,
but I love intimate venues, man.
A tiny, there's no way to get,
there's no way to get that feeling
of how when you're there all,
it's all different,
man.
There's no way to get that feeling of
13,000 people either except for fucking
that a fucking arena. Different feel. It's
all different, man. It's all different.
It does. It's all worth it. Yeah.
I think you gotta be on a
steady diet of everything. Yeah.
It's like you don't want to be just a
carnivore and only do 13,000 seat arenas.
You don't want to be just, who
is it? Who's your carnivore?
Who is at Jordan Peterson?
Is that how of this? Yeah,
he's the only one of them that I know.
I know several people that are
on the cardboard diet. I can't,
I can't get innocent because
I still like bullshit.
I'm not going to not have
ice cream once in a while.
I'm not going to not have a fucking
couple of French when I'm that guy.
I'm going to work out, but I'm also going
to have and do what the fuck I want.
I just, I can't get on that train. I
suffered for a while doing a crazy diet.
Would you do, I did.
I did. I did this. Um,
it's almost like a circuit
likes how circuit workout is.
It's like circuit dieting where
it's like one week without,
do you know what that is?
No. Yeah, you did. You, you,
you get rid of an element that's kind
of a vice, right. Whether it's like a,
and if it's a, it's gotta
be a heavy vice, right?
Like it's like I've high
amounts of sugar in my diet,
so it's like I do a week completely
without sugar and then I do a week without
meeting. Then I did a week without
you, I don't know, fish or whatever.
I kept changing what it was to find
how my body reacted to it and I fucking
hated it. The fucking
hated it. I was like,
I'm a much more balanced person up here
in my work and my writing in my exercise
and my sleep and my fuck life when I just
get to eat what I want. Regimented Lee,
that's a fake word. Fuck. Life.
Regimented life. It's a better question.
Fuck lights the name of my new album.
That's a good law.
Now she get that tattooed across his
fuck life.
I'm much better. Why do you
say fuck life? No, no, no, no,
no, no, no. The fuck, fuck,
life. The fuck life. You know, I'm into
my fucking on the pump. Got Bug life
regimen regimen. Mentally,
mentally. Regimentally see
that sounds fucking wrong.
Regimental lead like I'm better off when
I just, when I do, when I just balanced,
when I go, I don't need that
shit. I should need that bullshit.
And I poke in and out things
once in a while. It's, that's
just, I don't know man.
I think that's almost like,
that's the only way to live for me to
wait for it to work. I've tried shit.
I can't do it.
Yeah.
I think people like going on diets cause
it gives them something to concentrate
too. That's what I'm saying.
I have shit going on.
I can't worry overtly all day long about
like, is this meal going to, is like,
how am I going to get fucked that shit.
But that's one of the things that
people like about it. Like, okay,
I'm on this diet now I gotta concentrate
this. Is it like meal prep? Really? Um,
yeah.
Or meal prepping.
And Sunday prepping all up inside of me
where I look at my shows in Melbourne
for trader, no prep. I am in control of
my world, asteroid hurdling towards us.
I'm a complete control of him in control,
getting rocket space.
I have a finite lifespan.
I have to constantly eat and shit,
but everything's fine. Everything
else is okay. Everything's fine.
My buddy texted me today by
the way, I was, he goes, uh,
he had a concern I talked about on
another podcast about how he couldn't,
he didn't shit for like five days.
Oh.
I have a buddy who went through that and
he went to the doctor and he has this
thing and he had to get help
for, he texted me, he goes,
I just want to let you know I'm back
from vacation. I feel really good. Also,
I'm shitting like normal again.
And I was like,
I feel like a like a really proud friend.
Like he, he was really struggling.
He was nervous about it. He was like,
dude, I haven't shit in like four days.
I was like four fucking days.
Who was the guy that had
worked with on fear factor.
I don't want to shame them so I won't
say his name and he wants it out there.
Great Guy. Um, he had a real
problem, a real problem.
It was packed in there for days and days.
It wasn't coming out and he could feel
it like you could touch his bottle and
feel it inside. It was
hard. It's hard grows.
So fiber dog had to go to a doctor and
they literally had to chip it out of his
asshole, shut the fuck allocated,
impacted it chisel in his blood hole.
They had to get in there and break it up
and then they had to make him take this
like really intense laxative.
So it takes this really intense laxative,
like like weapons grade
laxative and they're in,
they're chipping away at the stone wall,
which is essentially just like a
dam to keep all this shit juice.
It's piling up.
Dammed it because he's got the impacted
dried out shit that should have been out
of his body days ago.
And then he's got the fresh shit
on top of that. At the top of that,
he's got this camera goal laxative that's
just sending off explosion the side of
the dock.
It was a fucking hammer hammer and a
screwdriver just whacking at the ship rock
that's at the bottom of his asshole and
then it breaks loose and just explodes
everywhere. Fuck. Like he
gave birth to a dead seal.
Just fly it out of the capsule bag.
All right, we got it. We got it.
How much did you, how much weight
did you lose? I don't know.
But he said it was awful.
It was awful. Like they had to pry the
shit out of his ass and break it up.
It kind of paints pains. Those downstairs
to payments. I can't imagine from,
you're not shitting. Yes, it's it. What's
it called? A, um, you give yourself, um,
imagine that. What's it
called? Come on. Look it up.
You know what I'm talking about?
It's it now, but there's a,
there's a word it's called, it's like
a toxic, like toxic shock syndrome.
And that women get, if they leave like
a tampon into too long. Yeah. If you're,
if you don't shit for a certain amount of
time, you, you poison yourself. Mm. Yeah.
It starts to leak into your
organs and shit. Something,
it's something absurdly Gr. I just, there
was a sh, uh, one of those like, um,
a 600 pound life or whatever those shows
are, this woman wouldn't shit. And she,
she, which kept holding on, holding on
and they're like, purpose. Yes. Why?
Because she didn't want, she couldn't
move to shit. She was so fucking big,
she couldn't move to shit.
So the shit packed up and they were like,
you're gonna fucking die.
It's going to get in your bloods.
It's going to get in your, uh, your other
organs in your bloodstream and kill you.
It like,
doesn't that freak you out when you watch
a show like that where someone's like,
like,
uh,
uh, what are those called? Hoarders,
like a hoarder or someone who's gaining
a ton of weight or something to get
there, but you know, that you could get
there. You know, you couldn't get there.
But you know that a person could
get there. Yeah, right. You right.
You now Andrew Santino May, 2019
you're, I are going to get there. No,
probably not.
You're fine.
But some people how bad road and they
can't turn around. They're stuck.
Yeah. And h but they compile it. Right?
Cause that cause the depression feeds
the hunger feeds the depression. Yeah.
What does that,
that's shit constantly.
[inaudible] died after
feces filled bowel burst.
Oh look how much shit there's there.
His rectum a dilated up to 18 centimeters
inside his body and was filled with
feces according to the BMJ
24 he's a child.
24 this isn't some 80 year old man who
just is like, wow, he's autistic. Right?
Okay. It's chronic constipation. Oh,
okay. Well Great. Now we feel bad.
Jamie. Thanks. Jamie. Fox
baiting us with some shit.
Still look at that guy and almost died
from constipation. So it's a few people.
Every year they had to surgically remove
two liters of poop up coca cola bottle
filled with poop to leaders to lead it.
Think of a liter bottle of coke and
picking two of those fill with sand and
stuffed up your ass shit and your ankle
is sand leading to a lack of blood flow
to the leg and was pressing on his
artery, bro. Oh my God. It was,
his shit was choking his leg out.
That's what was happening.
Shit was just Chinwag Army Shit Hospital
for 23 days and took 13 days for you
could walk again. I'm like, boy,
no explanation has been found yet as to
explain his significant faecal loading,
uh, loading constipation,
looking the spell, fecal
f, a. E, c a.L is that
because they're in Australia?
Fucking those idiots.
The guy was probably bang kangaroos or
something and he caught some disease.
Those people, no time to pope. I'm
faecal loading bang and Kangaroos.
Have you heard of that?
Um,
coupled that they ate a raw rat heart
from Mongolia and they got the black
plague. What? Yeah, they died,
exists the black plague from
fucking fucking crazy people. Liver.
That's what it was.
A liver.
They ate a raw rat liver and
they died of the bubonic plague.
Why did they eat it?
Take or bubonic plague?
I think it'd be Bonac play black sounds
like it. Yeah. It's gotta be bond.
They have a bionic play.
What's the difference? Cause
Obama plague was a bacteria,
right? Well what's the black plague? That
was a virus, right? Wasn't that a virus?
What do you at Doctor? Not,
not anymore. I got disbarred.
Apparently you're not going to like keep
them. You can't keep the faecal loading.
So you were in college. What did you think
you were going to be comedian. Really?
Yeah, like this is a waste of time.
It's just funny because I had my,
my modeling throwing shown Andrew
Santino no case on his phone. Yeah.
Fuck that shit. One of those
gangs, the black plague was a,
an event during a time period and the
13 hundreds and the bubonic plague is a
thing you can get right.
But the black plague the plague was what?
A viral disease that was killing people.
Right?
So it's the bubonic plague that these
folks got and they got it from eating a
raw rats, heart or liver. Think it's
liver can look at us. What does this,
kidney, Kidney, oh, that's in high
school. Why would they kidneys?
Is it something that you wrote? Yeah,
that's in high school. Oh my God.
That you wanted to be a comedian and says,
I wanted to be, I want to be a queen.
I want to stand up comic and to
work with comedy on television.
Yeah. I'm willing to do whatever
it takes. Make It. Yeah.
So it says I want to do anything. I like
what I'm hearing. Whatever it takes,
whatever it takes. Look at, I wrote below,
I want you to wear a track suit with
no underwear and meet me at the doc.
Got It. We're going to get on my
yacht. You got good time. Let's go.
And I got a part for you
to read my script. Oh,
imagine some guy takes you out on
his, on his yacht. You're like, wow.
So you really think my tape was good.
Ah, yeah, you tape tapers. Amazing.
We're going to show you
that are listening. And he,
he brings you this script and it
tells you what's required of you.
And then you're out there in the middle
of the water bobbing around staring at
this guy and he got a couple of
glasses of wine. He was like,
I'm gonna make you a star. I
need to get my dick sucked. Okay.
I gotta get that Shit. I get it. I did
write in high school anything it takes.
Now imagine being a woman
and you're in that situation.
You think you're gonna be able to
sweet. Talk to that guy. Right?
That's why you were flirting with them
and that's why he got close to him. He's,
you're going to get a part you to
play him. You got to get apart.
Next thing you know, you're on
that ocean. Well that feels creepy.
That feels rapey and is rapey right?
When you're a dude, you'd be like,
fuck that guy fucked up. Just sacrifice
man. For the role that I'm saying.
It's a different feeling.
Totally,
but still dangerous because if the guy
finds out that you're not willing and
then you might be hostile and then he
might be hostile back like your two dudes.
One Dude want to get his
dick sucked by a dude,
but you're both two dudes and it's a real
hair raising situation for both of you.
What are your healing for
him? It's hair raising, right?
You tried to get this guy to
suck your Dick and the guy said,
I'll fucking kill you.
And you're like, Jesus.
Now I gotta drive this guy back
in my boat. It just me and him,
a guy who said he would kill me,
a 20 foot long little boat. Yeah.
You got to sit while you got to make him
sit up by the bow and you'd just drive
quietly. Do you do jump in and log?
That's where people kill people.
Like you know he's going to tell people.
Yeah, totally. That's how he gets good.
That's why that's where that
kid from Iowa goes missing.
Went to Hollywood for big dreams,
never came back, is out on the water.
Cement shoes my friend put on the shoes.
Yeah,
I guarantee that's happened.
But I guarantee you the guys tried to
get a guy to suck his dick and the guy
tried to fight them and they
fought to the death academy.
I'm sure it's happening now.
There's got to be right as we're speaking,
there's gotta be listening to this murder.
Gay Guy is choking them to death.
Doesn't want anyone to know. Don't go on
the boat unless you really know the guy.
That's my, that's my message. How well
do you know the guy, man or women,
if the guys a producer and he takes
you on the boat, don't go on the boat.
I feel like that about it. How well do
you know the guy with the boat? Not that,
well,
I'm not going on the guy's fucking vote.
I was on a show once and there was
a guy who was kind of a, he was a,
I don't want to be mean, but he was
sleazy. You're just a Hollywood.
How's that mean? Calling out
someone for being fucking sleazy.
Sleazebag but it's the most
stereotypical version of, ah, and uh,
there was a Gao who's also
working on the television shown,
choose young and flirtatious
and next thing you know,
they were on his boat for the weekend
working on the script and they came back.
We were like, it's like you really
just said that. Yeah, we are,
we're guys creatively, oh
gosh. Working creatively,
just out in the middle of the water
the water gives me, and being at Unis,
the water makes me feel a type of way,
but it's like normal stuff.
Like that's what people did for this
business. Yeah, he used to be. But Jamie,
you wanted to bring this up because you
can sort of talking about that and we
never, oh, well this was a
different subject, but I'll save it.
This is a Ed buck. Do you know
who that guy is? Like, no,
he's like this democratic,
uh, he's a a donor. Oh, right.
You and I talked about were 10 to
two dudes had been found dead there,
um,
from drug overdoses.
So they'd come over and one guy said that,
what did he say?
That.
I don't know what they've said,
but like I think with him makes him do
drugs or he or he's taking them in while
they're already super high and
he's helping them out or something.
They die and they ended up dying water.
They're claiming that he's helping two
people that I think that's what it is.
Coincidence is maybe he's telling
the truth. Maybe like, yeah,
he goes out there and finds really high
people keep trying to save people in the
middle of the night. What do
you cynical bro? Yeah, Dude.
What do you think is happening? You want
me to take a wild guess? Yeah, I bet.
He goes out looking for people that
are real fucked up to get back to his
apartment to get some
fucking Dick. What? No Way.
And then that side that's, and then
they say, do you have any more drugs?
And he goes,
you bet I got more fucking drugs.
They do more drugs together and they die
and he dies and he stays alive. Whoa.
You sure? Case closed, your honor. Are you
oh directed. I rest my second gentleman.
Mr. Buck. Okay. Well it
looks like a fine man.
It looks like he doesn't do anything like
he's got a nice gold tooth shining in
the back of his mouth. Like a, what's his
name? The wet bandits from home alone,
investigators found multiple sex toys,
multiple syringes and clear
plastic bags with suspects.
Suspected methamphetamine in a toolbox
roll cabinet in the living room.
He's got a tool box filled with
syringes and sex toys. Let's go to work.
Clear plastic bags with meth.
More has been homeless and how it worked.
How it says Ma bags.
Clear plastic bags like more than many.
He's got bags of speed.
He had been homeless and it
worked as an escort. Yeah, that's,
he was on that Gigolo show. Season Four.
He was one of the main guy. He's the guy.
I become addicted to.
Drugs in the Bush is the one to thank you.
Gave me my first
injection of crystal meth.
I become addicted to drugs and
the worst one at that. Well,
I don't know if that's true,
but it's crazy story that the,
what we do know is true is two
people died over there. Yeah.
That's fucking insane.
He's all, oh, hey man,
it's just g is there, there's different
standards, right? Like here's,
here's the thing,
like if that guy,
if he was a heterosexual guy and
two women had died at his house,
prison for life, what are the odds
that they wouldn't arrest him?
Zero. Zero, zero. Zero. If one woman is
found dead in your fucking apartment,
yeah,
if you could,
we're going to go to Chris hookers
and shoot them up with meth. Yeah,
you go to jail, go to prison.
But if you pick up mail, look,
it's like what we were talking about
earlier. If it's a guy like, ah,
you're a Russian model. You came
over here to that work, Bro.
Fuck the old ladies come on.
Like, that's true. But these guys,
two guys are dead and
everybody's like, Hey, you know,
that's the fucking game they're playing.
They Odi playing that shoot the
math game. Once you shoot Sean, you,
he's the only killed two guys. What
the fuck? That's kind of like the, the,
what is it? The, uh, the, the staircase.
You know that documentary where like two
of his wives died falling downstairs.
Oh yeah. That's, people are like,
what? You still fucking know.
You think two women
coincidentally magic they did.
They're your favorite people ever
and they just kept falling and pop it
literally impossible. What if you're a
rock climber there? It was in his kitchen.
Is it is fucking kitchen. Did he
throw second? Al Did it. What's this
crazy dude? He has such a fluid.
He said a bird flew in and scared her
and flew out of the home because there
wasn't no fucking bird by the way.
But he said a bird flu and scared her
and she fell down the stairs backwards.
By the way,
you know how hard it is to fall back
down the stairs backwards when you,
when you're already at the top of a stair,
nobody falls backwards when they're
walking upstairs. Kicked Sparta,
someone has to hit you down the that's
exactly the, the lawyer was like,
somebody pushed you down the stairs.
That's the only way that happens. Sparta.
Sparta,
fuck you.
If they did an autopsy and they see the
footprint right in the middle of her
chest.
Well they said the blood splatter was
like so obviously consistent with someone
that was like thrown downstairs.
Well the how will god her Bro
and these hours are doing that.
That is a thing that happens off fly
into your home. They fucked shit up.
They're not good guests. They're
not nice people. Assholes. Yeah.
They really are truly not nice.
There's such a cool animal. Yeah, they
are. They're a weird animal that we like.
Think of them as these wise
old creatures. Like we, we,
we have like an anthropomorphic version
of an owl. Yeah. That's really smart.
Like an owl is like, well
yeah, like read off the, uh,
find out what's going on. The tootsie
pop owl. How many licks does it take?
That was like he wore glasses.
Yeah. Well that must be what it did.
But the wise old owl is like
an adage, right? Yeah. Why
is it though? I Dunno man.
Because they're fucking ruthless.
What they are is just cunts that's
swooped down and kill rabbits. Rabbits up,
man. They're wingspans are fucking
incredible. When you see them take off,
take flight and it comes snag something.
It's,
it's wild to safe driving home once and
one was flying over my head and I guess
it didn't like how low it was as
to where my car was on the road.
Like hit had picked a path
probably not in its head.
Understanding the cars go down this
road. Right. It was flying. Right, right.
And the car was just too close.
Who just dropped the rabbit
and went to get it later.
I pulled over cause I'm like, what
the fuck was that? Because it was big.
Like whatever it dropped was
a fairly large creature and a,
I went over in this rabbit that was just
gutted because the first thing they eat
is the guts. Right. So to just
torn the guts out of this rabbit,
they pick it apart and then they take the
rest home with them. They swooped down.
Have you ever seen a, an OWL's clause?
Yeah, they're fucking nasty. Either.
Huge giant ass clause that the
coolest video. Look at that thing.
Look at the closet that they're bad ass.
Dude, I mean, God, it's an amazing one.
Predator. The first picture, it looks
like him saying don't take a picture.
And in the second one he's like,
why did you take the fucking,
I told you not to make a pitch cause
it's like mad at you and she's picking it
up.
Look at the eyes
in that thing, man. I mean,
it has a demonic face that's
like beautiful Predator man.
It's an incredible animal.
Um, but look at that one.
There's an amazing video
online of one killing hawk.
It kills a hawk in its, in its
nest. It swoops down in the night.
They got a trail camera,
Frodo. They had these, this,
these hawks that were in this nest
and these a wildlife biologist.
We're filming it and
this, this ego, this uh,
owl comes in and watch this and just
snatches the Hawk right from the nest.
Watch this.
Here comes in the distance.
You'll see it's a little eyes any second
now it's crazy shit to watch the little
baby Haka. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
A little baby. Look at that.
Watch this motherfucker come in and
look at this like, Oh shit bitch, whoa,
fuck, that's a wrap. Son snatched it.
I'll get the mom is like, what happened?
What happened? I don't even
know what. That's a mom.
That might also be another
baby. It's pretty big though.
Yeah. It's hard to tell.
It's hard to tell because we don't
have a perspective. But look at this.
Look how it snatches it.
Bang.
Just to hand look all
the feathers of fly off.
Two hands grabbing a hold.
I don't know why that freaks me out so
much now. That freaks me the fuck out.
Bird on bird. Violences weird, crazy
dude. It is bird lives matter man.
But it's bird on bird violence is strange
cause it's almost like a cannibalism.
It's, it happens so often. Yeah. Is Jack
Birds because they don't give a fuck.
It doesn't matter. They don't give a fuck.
But do you think that's a last resort?
Kind of. They don't really want
to eat other birds, right, bro?
Everybody eats birds or the next picture.
Even birds.
It's a bird swallowing
chick. Yeah, look at it.
Look at it bucking and it's his throat.
Fuck what a Twat.
Fuck. That's a fucking whole
duck. That's huge. Yeah. Yeah.
Look at that thing. That
is huge. Well it's a check.
It's not a fully grown duck but,
but it's big.
It's big enough that it's crazy
that that thinks swallows it.
You know the one of the really
fucked up ones and I saw a recently,
I saw a toad eat a rat or
a mouse. I totally want to
see that. Your mouse? Yeah.
He's either frog or a toad.
I don't know what it was.
But a big ass green frog looking
type creature swallowed a mouse hole.
Watch this. This is it. Yeah. This
is crazy dude. Oh this is not,
it does not it because this one is hidden.
There's one that's not hidden.
There's one where you could see it
like in like a little glass container.
Damn. I wish I could find it.
Um, cause it's a really good one.
It's from like a top down view.
That's pretty good. Watch this.
I didn't think that frogs ate mice, man.
I used to think the frogs are like, oh,
you know, they just get bugs, bugs out of
the air watch. He's just waiting. Not yet.
Not yet. I want to make sure I get them.
Making sure. Yeah. I'm sniff around. Oh,
you're close to maybe move a
little baby move. I'm on you.
And as soon as I decide you're lined up,
fuck you. Look at that
head first. Just lead it,
stuffing it in there with
his greedy little fingers.
I mean think about what a pro,
get them a house trying to get out.
The mouse is trying to get out
because they don't have teeth. Right?
So they just got to swallow that.
Get Out. Its head is out, man. Look,
it's eating ass asshole first.
Jesus Christ. The mouse is
like, let me just let me,
I'm just curious me.
But I guess eat the butthole first
cause that's the worst taste.
So it gets a bad taste out of how they're
thinking. That's just where it was.
I think it would have eaten it
head first too. But look at it.
It's just blinking slowly
swallowing the mouse.
Imagine you being able to eat a dog.
That's what that's like
the size difference.
That's like you eating a German shepherd,
German shepherd and just stuffing anymore
face. Dislocating my jaw putting it in.
How big is a frog's mouth?
That's crazy,
but that's I guess when you see those
things I can dislocate their jaws.
I think that's incredible. Animals
that can fucking unhinged their job.
Snakes and snakes, that shit.
These are fasting charts.
Found them in California
again off the class after.
They haven't been here for 30 years and
they just weren't showing up again off
San Francisco Center or whatever.
What the fuck they they swim through
like little schools of fish and they just
swallow. I've seen that. It's
a basking shark. Giant mouth.
Yeah. Wild looking thing.
Just like a funnel for the ocean. How many
bottle caps are those things? Swallow?
Yeah. He was like, what you want to talk
about? Plastic straws, 30 feet long.
Imagine what kind of shit impacted
like six pack tops are assholes.
So many old cans of Colin Miller lite
blood streaming out of their asshole in
this shit. Those things.
Got It. They'll say,
you've got to be able to handle
anything after all these years.
They've swallowed so much bullshit.
Yeah.
Boots and fucking license plates
to build both parts. Bones,
all that shit. Yeah. Creepy shift
from the bottom of the fucking ocean.
Whale found dead with 13 pounds of
plastic in its stomach. Holy Shit.
13 pounds were so gross.
So there was a guy named that.
You see that? What does this
flip flops and 115 drinking cup.
They can't say red solo cups,
but that's what that is.
People out there partying far down on
that boat and I'm sperm whales. Wow. Damn,
that's fucked up. And flip flops.
I've probably had one of those flip.
I've lost so many pairs. I'm one of
mine is in his sperm whales. Oh Wow.
Did you see the video? That Beluga
whale returning the girl's cell phone?
What you did? Okay. Yeah. It's
fucking, if they set this up,
it would have been an amazing setup.
But I'll show you the video. Whoa.
Returning a girl south.
You Go.
The whale understands
objects are important to you.
She knows I phones are expensive and it
was how far it got dropped down in the
water. But you know, pull it up here.
It's going all over Instagram and Twitter.
You can use the find the video. I mean
it's coming from the depths of the water.
So like I don't know how the fuck this
and fuck I fucking God holding onto her
phone and it brings it up.
Like I don't know how you would fake that.
Well I they don't look like trainers.
It doesn't look like it's in like a,
you know what I mean?
Like it looks like it's in the water and
it says it's the one that was captured
last week. I don't know if that
the same one. That's the part.
I think he was fake about it, but, oh,
how do they know? How would they know?
It's the same one,
but the ones that have it.
I think that that's how I initially
saw the story and I don't lie.
Don't believe that they're tagged
and tracked. And I the white whale,
the white whale that we posted about
last week, well it stuck around.
He's been staying at Hammerfest and then
for, well maybe it's a different one.
Yeah. Maybe it's a whale that they saw
and not the one that was captured with the
harness. I think that's what's
wrong. They're just, well,
what did they post about last week? Go
to, they'll go to there. That's the one.
This is where that story came from
and know that's the part why I was so,
it is the same story. Yeah, it's
trained. It's a trained well, yeah.
Maybe you wanted food, man. Yeah, I just
thought it was going to get something.
Fish. Bitch. She, that's so
funny out there. Here's your
phone she had, they're like,
thank you. And he's like, no bitch fucking
feet. And he's just like the monkeys,
man. Give Up. Give up the
foods. You Bitch. That's what
I've come to steal from you.
I'm stealing.
Oh,
that was the other thing that we got
Margarita's and we left like a pitcher of
Margaritas out and they dumped the
picture over and drank the Margarita.
They like to party. So the monkeys
are probably partying on our porch.
They'll leave Margarita's out. Dude.
They're gonna fucking say hammered.
They get wasted. They must get so
hammered like a picture of mark.
I don't know how much they lapped
up after it spilled. Right.
I imagine they probably just drank
every drop. There was nothing left.
They knocked over the pitcher and some
of it must have stayed in the picture and
these are like,
this is what we want.
And they started drinking it and they
knock on your door like you have salt.
You guys didn't live in the fucking
salt out. Okay. He's drinking. Yeah,
he's boost out. They drink booze. This
is crazy. Drunk monkeys call Nicola.
They love Coca Cola. Oh yeah, look at
him. He doesn't know how to drink those.
Anything with sugar. They love sugar
shifts to Fau. He's hammered. Look at him.
Oh there. Put a draw. Oh my God. There's
videos of drunk monkeys there. Fucked up.
Look at him. They gave him wrestle
these fall down. That's hilarious.
Oh that people spill it off of drinks
that they're licking it off. Check tables.
If I had a monkey, I get him drunk every
day. Me and that monkey, we just party.
If everything goes totally south with me,
you're going to find me on key west.
Live in like those psycho white people
just drinking with monkeys going to be
messy. Yeah. It'll be the next one. Just
like that. But I'll stay in America.
Make girls poop in your mind. I
don't think he does that, bro.
And you should stop saying that he did.
Key West is a key West Key West is the
furthest you can get and still be in
America.
Is it rather than Alaska?
Some of the most ridiculous
thing to call that America.
That's like not even connected to Florida
and there are those people that live
down there. They might as well be ex
pats living on an island somewhere.
That's what it is. Right. Hurricane there.
Every 13 days they'd just get wiped out.
The southern most point.
Yeah, southern most point.
But I mean it's not just that they're
there, the keys. They're islands. Yeah.
I think you have to drive over land
like they're not really America. No,
it's its own little thing. It's like
Puerto Rico. The US Virgin Islands. Yeah.
Get the fuck out of here. How do we
own Guam? Yeah. How? What's that?
What does that to us there? Yeah.
That's way away from Hawaii.
It takes forever to get
there.
How do we get this fucking far
Hawaii's five hours by jet?
No, no, no. This is America.
America. I liked that.
I liked that we protect Hawaii,
but I think Hawaii is its own fucking
thing that those people were on their own
country and you know what would happen
immediately. Mushrooms should be legal.
That'd be the place to party. They voted
this week. A bunch of places voted.
Denver tried. Yeah. Denver
didn't make it though.
47% I think setting those old ranchers,
those old ranchers came
out of the mountain.
Those farmers actually do
it on the way here. I saw,
I saw hilarious on the bed of a
truck on the back of a truck window,
had a big thing that says what's going
on and it said it had a pot leaf and it
said legal and then it had a hose
watering a lawn and it said, illegal.
What's going on? Oh my God, look
into it. That's what he's saying.
What's going on. Dumb ass
called the drought. Fuck.
What's in the draft went away.
You can grow water conserving water.
You fuck head fuck coupons,
plants.
Fuck you can eat it had hey easy.
She about the guy in Florida that got
arrested because he would not take I eat
ass off the back when we were
talking about that I eat ass.
You eat ass said on
the back of his window.
He said it is his first amendment right
to let everyone know that he eats ass.
It is. Yeah, but that's a funny
thing. Imagine if that's your boy.
You have this little baby sucking on your
nipple and you're like my cute little
boy.
He's adorable.
Oh my little Billy wants to play baseball
but he doesn't like getting up early
and he misses a lot of practice.
He got cut from the team and
now he's kind of depressed.
He just plays Madden all
day and in one day bill,
he's got a pickup truck and Billy's
pickup trucks as I, he asked, right?
You come home and he's still living at
your house cause he's a fucking loser and
you come home and you see a little Billy
with his I eat ass and do you really
need to have that on your truck
and I drive what I do do more.
That's how I get my ass to eat. A lot
of guys don't put our dudes who I love.
I know I do. I do. I do.
I and the dad is like, I still
support them and I love him very much.
I also eat ass.
Got It from your mom and you're driving
on the highway and you're stuck in
bumper to bumper traffic with e ass in
front of you for an hour. We'd laugh.
My mom would laugh. My mom would get
mad at me for staying in the same lane.
Watch here in this lane because you think
it's funny that I have to look at eat
ass. I didn't say that mom. I did
not say that. It is funny though.
You think it's funny.
It is very funny.
Do you think it's funny because
my story about that guy,
I know you'd think it was,
I think it was more positive than that.
I think he wanted to let people know that
he eats ass because he's got this ma,
he's got an, I don't know if you know him,
but we know him. I know him very well.
Jamie and I know him very well,
but he's got this half of his tongue
was bid off by a dog when he was young,
so he knows how to eat ass rough. Yeah,
he's got it wrong at the end of it.
A little bit. Yeah. He knows how to flip
it around. Move. He's good at eating ass.
But I think people for years where
like you can't eat ass anymore Mike.
And he was like,
fuck you guys man.
What are you trying to say to
another Florida Man Story? Eating ass
man arrested after caught eating
ass inside toys r US store.
That's why they closed down.
That's why they're not in business.
That's a bold move. Little kids in
there. Oh, I know what I saw it.
So around here somewhere it
said the thing that game is,
there's a monkey on the cover and he's
got a hammer. He's trying to whack
the moles and there's guys
in this girl's pug guys,
he didn't girls poop.
Mommy,
you imagine if you saw a dude
eating an asshole underwear,
middle of toys r us. You're walking
around with your kid. Go, she'll,
but should we get,
what should we get a wiffle ball bat?
You want to play wiffle ball football?
And he tried to call
it and then a girl and
she goes, get out of here. Well, down a
rabbit hole with this one with ass eating.
Yeah,
man.
Who ripped out girlfriends intestines
for yelling her husband's name during sex
gets life in prison.
Makes perfect sense.
What man who ripped out his girlfriend's
intestines for yelling at that point?
I get mad. Fidel Lopez told investigators,
I get really, really mad. He,
he ripped out her intestine for
yelling out her husband's name,
but that's a complicated story.
Awesome. Florida. Oh no shit.
She called me the name
of the other fucking guy.
He told investigators after September,
2015 murder and she said it twice and
she was wrong and she was confusing me
with him at that point. I get mad. I would
get really, really mad. Oh Jesus Christ.
As the 31 year old lay stricken,
he shoved objects into Miss Nemesis,
vagina and anus, including a beer
bottle of hair, iron, even his fist.
And this is not, this guy's a psycho.
This is not something I needed to see.
Let a piece of me, Jesus Channel
is go. Are you reading about this?
Is something wrong with you? Where
do you find that stuff, Jamie?
Why do you go looking for your
saved pages? We'll try to sell you.
This is the images of I eat asked Florida
man, and I just started scrolling down.
Okay,
we go to Jamie's like Google ads.
It's all duck tape and crowbars and
shit. Hey, what's up with all this up,
all the handsaws on on man.
This is how you know that even
when you clear your search engine,
it doesn't matter because I
clear my shit sometimes and,
and even if I want to go back to porn hub,
it's still knows my suggested shit.
So creepy look into it.
Time to look into it,
time to look into the porn. That's where
there, where people are making money.
It's from cookies and like using your
information and your data and finding out
what you're interested in selling
it to advertisers. It's all very,
very sorted stuff to Zuckerberg
has got us, dude. Yeah,
there was a car parked
us. I mean it's just this,
a lot of it's weird that that sort of
escaped the imagination of people that
were like looking towards the future.
Like they didn't think that data
would be so valuable. Nobody really,
nobody really saw that 20 years ago when
the Internet was first coming alive.
Like nobody ever thought they'd be
able to like check your searches.
Like when they figured out how to make
a search engine then tied it into what
you're searching for and selling that to
advertisers. God, it's genius, but it's,
it's crazy that they can make so much
money. It's like you were talking about,
well, it's not right that you can make
so much money telling jokes. Well,
it's really not right.
You make so much money providing a
search engine off of the materials that
you've searched, what you're
supposedly, you're protected by, right?
You're supposed to think that
your searches are protected,
but on one hand, right,
like it's cool because you get all
this data, you get to this information,
but you know, you could literally
find out any answer to any question.
We do it all the time. Yeah. But
then the other part it's like, well,
what am I giving up? You get to now
they know what you like, what kind of,
what things you're thinking about
buying or what you are interested,
interested in, what movies
you like. They know that.
So they start selling you that I like,
oh well I guess I want them to sell it
to me. That's is what I like. Kind of.
It is a nice car. Wow. Look at that. All
right. Hit that movie does look good.
You know, and then you're like, oh my
Google is really working out well for me.
You want to become
autonomous with the machine.
It's just a big net as casting out
and just think if they put a chip in.
You mentioned you cool with the chip.
I've got one already,
but you've got the chip dot. Which,
which version though? Um, 2.6.
I don't know. I don't ask.
Just chip, chip me up dog.
You got to go to Langley, Virginia. You
go to where they kept Hannibal Lecter.
That's how they chip you. Chip you out
then Langley you got to go to the FBI,
but they have to know you're okay. I'll
get you a cool chip. May Dude, I'll chip.
Shut me the fuck up. What
would it take for you to, uh,
get chipped? Like for real,
if there was a chip and it provided
your gps tracking everywhere you go,
but you could read people's minds so the
government knew where you were all the
time. They do. But everybody else that had
a chip in it, you could read their mind.
Like you could see their intentions.
You could,
you could find out if they're upset, you
can find out the rational or irrational.
Maybe you could even show them the error
of their ways with your thoughts. Oh,
I don't want to just take that shit.
I want to know people's head
already know where you're at, man.
They've got your fucking phone.
They can have that.
I don't want to know what's going on it
like Jamie's had legal want to know is
fine. You know he's thinking
about right now food. Yeah.
It's like three of 20. You're gonna have
to move. We upgrade almost. Oh yeah.
That is like what it was like, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Remember why he got it.
But um, he was, he was
shot in a w spoiler alert.
He was shot in like a robbery
by armed gang members.
They shot him and paralyzed him.
And then this guy brought him back to
life with this chip in his spine that
regenerated spinal tissue and gave him
super powers and the new Kung Fu and all
kinds of other shit. Shit.
Me Dude. Yeah. John Carpay.
Jamie can out of here with me. You're
distracting the shit out of me today.
What's going on with you? I say
chip me up. Shut me the fuck up.
What do you about you, Jamie?
What'd you get distracted?
If you had a chip inside of you, would
you think about it all the time? Yeah.
The neural links scares the shit out of
him at the, basically the same thing,
right?
If you're wearing it? Yeah. Oh, you,
but do you think you'd like
that would become like,
you would think about that chip
all the time? No. No. You probably,
you'd definitely forget about it.
Forget about anything else
that you have and that you,
you forget about this thing that
this tracking device on a car,
as long as you could pick
it up and put it down,
but do you feel like you're
not really connected to,
yeah. No, you absolutely are.
But if you had something inside
of you, you'd be like, Ooh,
pull out when I really went for it. Okay.
The chip. Are you talking to it? Yeah.
I want to talk to it. The upgrade to
turn on my car. Get directions to Joe's.
Yeah, forget about it. Then it's close
to it, man. You have a, then you just,
then it becomes one with you.
It's not like you're thinking about it.
You're just acting. You're woke you up
in the middle of night. He'd be pissed.
Why would it wake me up?
I told him not to.
You know what I've been doing with a
Siri lately. The dumb bitch don't use it.
I tell her what to do. Um, I
make her make a notes for me.
Uh, so I go, Hey Siri, make a note
and what would you like to say
exactly right there. Whose phone
was that? Mine or yours or yours?
See that
she created a note.
She's listening to you, dude.
Hey, here we go. Hey Siri.
Make a note.
What do you want it to say?
Andrew Santino was the
last of the great gingers.
Okay. I created a note. Andrew Santino
was the last of the great changes.
That's a good, that was pretty,
beautified it out. She's pretty good.
You change was to, is did
you say is she did that. See,
but it's good enough for
me if I have ideas. If I'm
driving around, I have ideas.
I just tell Siri to do my dirty work
for me. It's the best I got. It's like,
it's made me capture so many more ideas.
I would never be able to capture
cause I'm driving. It's just funny.
I thought there was in
the shower the other day,
I spend an inordinate amount
of time thinking in the shower.
I really enjoy thinking in the shower
because it's really quiet and I'll sit
there and I'll think,
and sometimes I'll get a great idea and
in the time it takes me to get out of
the fucking shower, forget it.
I've washed it away. I want to,
I want a notebook. Like
A, yeah. Waterproof,
no board in the shower so I can write you
into one of those. Do they make those?
Yeah,
but your wife would get annoyed at you.
I have home sweet home sign and you
have a fucking thing over it so you can
write your stupid Oh, Dick in mom's pussy
is hilarious. No it's not. And I'll go,
you know what babe? I bought this
fucking shower. Why is that a joke?
Get outside Dick and mom's pussies
hilarious. What's wrong with you?
Get in the garage where you belong.
You're smoking pot with Theo Vaughn.
Vaughn says he doesn't smoke pot. I don't
believe him. You was just smoking pot.
Anybody who talks like that with all
those weird hey mans and gang a gang.
What is his, who is his gang
anyway? Tell him to fix his haircut.
Girls are getting mad at you.
The way your friends dress.
Tell him stop dressing like that
or the way your friends act.
Why does he do that? Why does he think
that's funny to throw stuff to do that?
Well cause he's funny.
It's fun. It's fun. When he
does that, I don't like it.
I don't like to so good thing you
and I are the same person. Yeah.
And you know what?
I can replace you.
Oh that's a threat.
You shouldn't say that to people.
They feel like you might,
you might replace, are we
all replaceable in every way?
Literally we're all replaceable.
I had Lex Friedman on yesterday from Mit.
He's a a,
a autonomous vehicle expert
in artificial intelligence.
Expert.
Creepy and interesting stuff.
But one of the things he was talking
about was like the movie her and that his
ultimate goal is to create something
that provides companionship to people.
I'm like, dude, so immediately
I think, can you fuck it?
And then I think if it's
a guy and it provides, uh,
if you want to gay boyfriend, sure,
can you make it be gay for you?
And that was like the big question.
Like if it is so smart that it's
like literally like a companion.
What if it's not gay?
And he was saying we have to face the
fact that robots are going to leave us or
grow.
We're going to make robots that leave us.
What the fuck's the point and make
it a robot unless it leaves you.
What the fuck?
And then there was an article about a
Pida that was mad at the folks that work
at Boston Dynamics
because Boston dynamics,
they make all these crazy robots and
they have incredible balance and they can
go running down hills and
shit and do back flips.
So these engineers were kicking these
robots that try to down dog. Well,
the dem, no, they didn't think it was
real dog. They were demonstrating that it,
you know, it can react to pressure
and it has balanced. Sure.
So Peter got mad and said they didn't
think it was cool that you kicked robots.
They're really talking about,
I don't even know why anybody would want
to do that too because you don't have
to find on if you can.
The only way to find out as your fucking
engineering works is you kick kick it.
It doesn't have feelings.
You fuck, but it does jail.
That's where you're
making mistakes happen.
The type of person that
you have to be to say,
I just don't think why any reasonable
person in front of kicked that rope.
Cause you've got to find out if he can
kick her fucking robot. How about this?
Come on, I'll, I'll pad that robot up
and kick the fucking shit out of it.
For a workout. Yeah. Like I would like
a robot that I could kick. It'd be dope.
I would like a robot that I could
kick a lot pads and move. Yeah.
I want to hit it. Oh, you want to hit
it right? I would like to fuck pads.
I want to be able to tee off on a robot,
man. If you have a real bite back though,
it looked, what if it moves at
like 30 or 40% that's all I want.
I want it to be a little dangerous,
but I want to be able to get my shots off.
But how do you know it's not gonna
fucking kill you? I don't say that.
That's probably, it's not going to
hurt. It's going to hit you. You know?
And I would know when I throw a leg kick
and it checks it and I hurt my Shin,
I'm like,
oh no.
When you hear it called Goshen to shit
on me and then it starts lifting up its
front leg and pressing for
it. I'm like, oh my God,
my role was going to
fuck me up or fucked up.
I got it mad stomps on your fucking head.
You would have to get something,
a robot that's made out of like heavy
bag material on the outside and then the
inside would just be some of a wire
framework that moves fairly crudely.
How do you stop it?
This is a thing.
You're creating a world where we're
going to get killed by robots.
How do you stop it?
That's the real question.
The real question is what happens when
they get so smart and so powerful that
they're tired of our nonsense
and this is going to happen.
But Lex and I were discussing and he was
talking about all the beauty in being a
person and the meaning and the meaning
that we have being a person and that was
agreeing with them. I mean, I love people.
I think that's one of the things that's
interesting about us is how much we
appreciate the things that we,
we all do.
We appreciate other people's art and
inspiration and even we appreciate the way
people look. We'd love,
we appreciate that. Yeah.
Something about the robots don't
give a fuck about all that. The,
my worry is that we could turn something
on that you can never turn back if they
become sentient, if they have the
ability to do whatever they want,
whenever they want to,
and they look at us when the sperm
whales with 150 flip flops in there,
but they're going to go,
what the fuck is wrong with
people and have we got to fix it?
Are they doing like, look
how gross they are. They,
they eat all the fish and they throw
their plastic in the water and whales are
eating.
They're plastic and dying and they would
look at all the stuff we do and then
we'll go wide. It kill us. Why
are we don't need you around?
You guys are worthless.
But we are so ego testicle
and so egocentric that we
can't imagine a world with
meaning without us, right? Because we are
everything. But even though we're finite,
we can only only,
only exist for a certain amount of time,
but leave behind a legacy
that other people could enjoy.
It doesn't matter if they're going to die
too though, does it, but it does matter.
It matters. While you're
alive. Okay, got it.
The universe doesn't give a fuck about
all that and all these crazy robots that
take over.
Imagine if we got to a planet one day,
I can imagine if we traveled the universe
and we managed to avoid creating some
sort of artificial intelligence because
we got hit with a solar flare that
killed the fucking power grid or
something like that. And when,
then we got wiser as a civilization and
then we got to a place where we could
travel and we traveled to another planet
and we got there. And those robots,
just robots, no humans, no humans.
And they were just running
around aimlessly because
they'd killed off all the
biological life.
And they just sit in there operating
on the sun with nothing to do and no
purpose and no reason to exist.
And like what happened and these crazy
monkeys that lived on this planet,
they decided to for an experiment,
make an artificial intelligence
and just let it go. Run a muck.
And what it did was eat everything it
lived off biological material to there's
nothing left.
And then it just sat there in the
sun and waited for someone to arrive.
No, that can never happen. Of
course it could. That's happening.
I'm thinking too deeply about where
I'm going to be when that happens.
Those Boston dynamic robots are going
to have a little pinchers on each arm.
Just wrapping everything in front of
them and stuffing them in their big giant
mouse. Cha Cha. What about the,
what about the role that's a turn
themselves back on? Didn't that happen?
Where was that?
Right.
That has shut of robot down in Korea
because it turned itself back on.
If there were shut off,
that's what's happening.
That's what's going to happen though.
The robots are going to start going, ah,
I want to be on right now.
I don't like being off.
It wasn't that something that
they were doing with Google.
Artificial people in new study struggled
to turn off a robot when it begged them
not to. Oh, begged them. Not too creepy.
I somehow felt sorry for him. Whoa.
Please don't tag me off. Chill dude.
That I'm telling you when that becomes
a real woman like x Mokena. Yep.
And you're in love with her and she
tells you to kill your boss. Yup.
I want to be with you, Andrew. You don't
need to go to work. Jamie's for full.
Jamie won't let us leave. Jamie doesn't
think I'm a real woman, but I know you do.
Like,
oh we got to,
that happened that we were on the way to
that happening and we made a deal with
them to leave us alone and we got to
go to north central island to exist.
Uncontacted showing them what would you
rather be eaten by a robot or live like
a savage savage. Oh my
God. Any Day of the week.
Let me live off the
grid forever like that.
As long as you're in a resource rich
place, I would take the money that bad.
They've lived there for a long time.
It's the size of Manhattan and there's
only 39 of them though. That ain't good.
Yeah, but that's also because how can
they repopulate their fucking each other.
That's what I'm saying.
So how you can only repopulate so much.
You can only continue to
repopulate within your own. Right.
What kind of gene pool they're drawn from.
It's only 39 of them.
They have to be fucking relatives.
They're all relatives.
There's no way they've got to,
there's no way.
They have a map on the island
of people that they're like,
you can't fuck her remap. Just keep
that in mind. They're like, well,
there's only 17 choices. Yeah,
it's only 39 of [inaudible] either.
I wonder if it's how many, if it's
male versus female, what it is,
but it's more dominant percent men
fighting for 15 girls or but fucking
[inaudible] get him the girls to
get pregnant. The only 39 of them,
because they're all gay
and like they go skate.
It's time to make a baby like now and wow.
Hey Girl started crows and
they run up to the tree tops.
Start Banging each other and
looking at the girls. Yeah. Growth.
Get really mad because they want a baby
surrounded by all these damaged said the
sad, the story of sets in
the island, dammit. Yeah.
They must be to say they're all cousins.
They're all fucking sick.
You had to live in the jungle.
What have you had to live in the junk
you'd live in the jungle look like in the
Amazon. Like I'd rather live in the
desert. The junk. Really? Yeah. Not me.
I live in a desert. Desert.
Desert. W were you going to do it?
Make a house out of sand. Fuck you.
Gonna do there. You had dialed there.
My dying while you've been a mountain.
First of all,
you can make a house in a mountain.
What carve it out was the last
time you were at a desert.
They don't have mountains
in a mother fucking desert.
Usually Los Angeles was a desert. These
are mountains all over the place. No,
you go to the mountains. It's not
desert. There are demos in the deserts.
Varied terrain. Arizona
desert. Desert mountains. Yeah.
They do have some mountains,
but they have desert and then they have
mountains. Does it know desert mountain?
Sure. There is no, once you get up
in the mountains, trees and shit. No,
not in Arizona. There's, that's true.
Some of them are rocky, right? Yeah.
Well,
you know what's the really coolest when
you go from like San Diego and you drive
through that area like into Arizona and
you find all those crazy rock formations
and Cheryl can beautiful out there,
man,
if you really stop and think about all
the different types of environment that
exists here in America where you go to
Yellowstone and see all that crazy shit
and then you can go to Miami and the
keys and see all that crazy shit.
You could be up in Maine and see the
frozen north in Michigan and Idaho and on
the train down to San Diego.
When we were going down there,
I was on the train and I had to had
one gentleman and this gentleman like
explore like I like I like I like,
I like a guy who likes to fucking
relax and not be in traffic.
I was sitting in the train and some
guy next to me was gone talking to some
young kid. Some young kid was
like, I want to go to Europe.
I think Europe is awesome. It's better
than America. It's an older guy.
He was like, this country has more to
offer than you could ever fucking dream.
And he was like, what do you, what do
you tie? What are you talking about it?
And he's like,
you can see the beauty of the mountains.
You can see the beauty of Alaska.
You could see that.
And he was explaining all this
stuff about that. He's like,
I've never left the United States and
I've traveled to almost every state and
every state gets better. And I
was like, ah, shut up punk. Yeah,
shut up you little punk bitch,
you little pussy.
He was pushing around that same agenda
though, that he was here. But it is true.
The more I travel, the more I'm like,
oh, this place is fucking gorgeous.
I would have never thought to come here.
If it weren't for comedy. I get to go to,
we get to go to places where I'm like,
I would have never traveled here.
There was no reason for me to go to
Virginia outside of for doing standup.
I was never going to vacation
there. I mean, that's true.
That's a good point. Yeah.
I was never going to go off.
And unless you're traveling for work,
how often are you traveling to these
kinds of cities? Just just check them out.
Yeah. Who does that? Maine. Maine
was fucking beautiful. I had no idea.
Main was that nice. Has like
eight people living in it. Yeah,
I was nine when I showed up.
I got a couple of kids there too.
This spots and main where you just drive
and all you see is woods for like an
hour. It's fucking beautiful though.
When you see that kind of like land,
like little towns that still just haven't
been like butt fucked by pop culture
influenced and still have their own thing.
We up to Bangor were Stephen King lives.
I think he's what they
call a snowbird now.
Like he lives in Florida and then
in the summertime he lives in Maine.
That's like my nightmare man.
He,
he lives in a house in the
middle of Bangor and like
you could drive to his gate
like his,
his gait is there and everybody knows
this is his house cause it's this big ass
house.
I bet it's a s k on the fucking gate.
Well it has the rod iron gates have
like gargoyles on them and shit.
So it's like everyone knows
it's his house kick shit.
But he gets like Weirdo showing up,
banging on his door and stuff,
trying to give her a script house.
Wow. Yeah. It's a dope old house.
But I mean he lives right,
doesn't there?
Doesn't it looked like Stephen King
lived there. Look, it is looking at the,
the winged creatures on is, what is
that? It's the Gargoyle, right? Yeah.
Cooley look, fuck that looks, that's
wild. He had that made, I mean,
it's so obvious that it's his house.
He's got a frog also. He loves frogs.
The frogs at fuck up mice
and shit. Yeah. He's um,
you know, I don't think Bangor has
a population of 100,000 people.
If I had to guess what state?
Bangor Maine. That's where he lives.
I didn't know as many, what's
the population of Bangor?
30 1030 1000 in a city.
My buddy was living up there and my friend
Marcus Davis was living up there and
he loved it. He's a fighter because
say there's no crime, there's no crime.
It's kind of hard when there's that
low of a population. Yeah. He's like,
it's really cold up there and shit, but
there's no crime. I still gigs up there.
I used to gigs up there
when I was living in Boston.
He drove three and a half hours to Bangor,
Maine in the last hour.
You have to make sure you get gas because
you got to drive an hour with no gas.
There's an does that Bangor,
that's fright. There is beautiful.
The mountain in the lake.
God, it's beautiful cotton.
Dana white keeps a place up
there in Maine. Yeah, yeah.
He's got a place in some other
part of Maine, like a beautiful,
like he's got a big spread up there,
a lot of land,
and he's like a vacation place where
he goes and brings his friends and they
just chill. That's it can,
I mean, it's interesting.
I don't know if that wouldn't be my
vacation place spot, but I guess, well,
it's fucking beautiful man.
And there's no one there and it's
gone and they can let you know.
I guess you just want to get
away from fucking society.
You know my vacation spot would
be in a lake, Louise and Banff.
What's Bam? Bam for national forest
is in Calgary. Oh, Lake Louise.
You'll probably see them. The prettiest
lake I've ever seen in my fucking life.
I think it's pretty country up
there, dude. Oh Calgary's gorgeous.
Fucking beautiful. But Lake Louise
in like specifically, I went,
I went to Banff national forest when we
were doing this thing and I was stunned
by how fucking look at that Lake
Louise. Ooh Man, that's so pretty.
There's some about a mountain
and a Lake Combo, right?
Mountains in a lake together.
It's like fishing.
I do like fucking fishing. I love
fishing. Don't get to do it enough.
I let me needed, that's a problem. But
I've been thinking about that lately.
Like I need to do more fishing. Like,
I see shit like that and I go, God,
I don't want to be out there like
catching northern pike having a good old
fucking time.
It's the best way to like hang out with
friends and just chill the fuck out and
talk shit and have a laugh and, and
if you can cook them on the shore, uh,
that's the best thing of frying
pan and cook it right there.
They're so delicious. Like you can't
believe how much more delicious they are.
Fresh fish is unbeatable. There's no two
different plays. So much better. Yeah.
Store bought fish. It's
just not the same. Yeah,
me and the missus caught some Mahima he
wants and then we brought it right back
to the, uh, to the place in Mexico and
they were cooking it at the resort.
And I was like, this is the best
fish I've ever eaten in my life.
I can't believe how good it also
circumstantial that you're like,
this is one of the greatest
kind of ways to have that.
So it also probably releases different
endorphins in your brain to be like,
I'm enjoying this more than I
ever would enjoy other fish.
But it was the first time I'd ever caught,
I would eat and Mahi Mahi that was her
super fresh. Like I had eaten it before,
but it was probably frozen. You
know what I mean? Not that fresh.
Maybe a day old pat. Yeah, but when you
eat it like an hour after you catch,
it's like, Holy Shit. Imagine
how salmon tastes the bears.
I catch them out of the fucking
room or in their office. So excited.
They get so fat they get so fucking
fat. Coastal bears. That's the big ones.
You know, brown bears and
grizzly bears are the same thing,
but brown bears are way bigger and
the reason why they're way bigger,
it's because they live on the coast,
so just eating fish and dead whales they
launched and anything else they can get
there. Fuck origin on fucking
fatty, fatty, heavy foods.
There's an awful video.
Awful. Jamie. I'll find it.
Of a grizzly that's polling black bear
cubs out of a den and killing them and
eating them and the mother
is trying to stomp them.
He's trying to stop the grizzly from
eating her babies and he just swats are
away like she ain't shit. I got
say, it's awful dude, you shouldn't,
shouldn't play it. It definitely cannot
play it and you shouldn't even watch it.
I'm gonna it.
The screens that they make and it takes,
it's a long ass video and she's trying
to fight him off but he's like, fuck you,
I'm eating your babies.
That's one thing that bothers me the
most about the anthropomorphization that
people do with animals is the,
their stance on bears is,
I don't want people to hate bears,
but I want people to know what a bear
really is versus what they think it is.
I think they're sweet.
They eat honey and they're sweet and
they're nice and they don't really fuck
shit up. They, they're amazing.
I'm a big fan of bears,
but they are all cannibals.
They're all cal bears make me feel like,
of course there were dinosaurs pairs
or like that's just a fucking dinosaur.
Well, it's a beast. This is what it
is. It's a beast in the purest sense.
So any beast make reminds me that we
definitely had had to have dinosaurs.
That that was just a small dinosaur. No,
it's nothing like a dinosaur's far, far,
far, far, far creep here,
they don't have any hair.
I don't trust anything with no hair.
You don't have any fucking hair.
I have a little,
I got out of my face get ugly,
but I don't trust anything that like
is hairless. Any hair on its body.
It's what other animals? What do you
mean? Like fish or hairless like a snake.
Everything in the waters hair list.
You don't trust those fox? None of it.
None of it.
That bottlenose dolphins I brought back
and they just found you don't trust that
dolphin and so that's a weapon
from Russia. It's awesome.
They want to put a bomb on that thing,
but we had a Russian strap on. It's back.
That's the whole did spoke Russian.
It had a Russian strap on its back.
Stope like the, the, the whale
that they're talking about.
They think the Russians had trained it
to get close to boats so that it could
hit the boat and blow it up.
Stope you don't care. I care.
Some things are cool.
I mean they're rendering of rex hair hair.
But I thought they think it has feathers
to think those are fair and looking at
it has red hair by the way, at the front
of its face. Well that's the other thing.
They think that it might've been because
they think they might been scavengers.
T rex was a ginger with freckles.
Where did you find this Jamie's holes?
Fucking Dick rule that no ginger's that
are assholes. How about a Dunn's word?
They're all over the place. Changes that
are assholes you can't not find. Look at,
there's nothing. Might've had
facial features like a vulture.
They think it might have been red
in the face cause they really don't
have any idea what the, I mean,
when you see these color drawings,
they just take chances.
They just are all made up.
The, um, university of Bozeman,
not the University of Bozeman and the
natural history museum, and Bozeman,
Montana has a raptor
that on one side of it,
they had feathers on it.
So it's hard to give you like an
alternate perspective of what it might've
looked like. So they had this
raptor and in one side of it,
it looked just like an, like an evil
bird. It's really cool because they,
they know now.
That's what it looked like.
They know now that a lot of
dinosaurs had had feathers.
They've actually got fossils
of dinosaurs with feathers.
So they know that the idea
that all dinosaurs were
these reptile looking things
is incorrect. Some of them literally were
birds. So the birds that you see today,
whether it's a peacock or a
chicken or something like that,
they're fucking dinosaurs.
That's what that is.
It's a dinosaur that survived the
ones that are bigger than a chicken.
It didn't really make it,
but the ones, you know,
why did the small ones making it will
hide that when the impact of the crater
hit the world, that it was so devastating.
They killed almost everything.
Kyla and every, whatever was
left, whatever, scrounging,
scavenging little creature that was left,
evolved and became us.
We used to be a mole. We used to be
like a shrew 65 million years ago.
That's what these people, these, these
nonbelievers is what they think you,
you think it's ridiculous that you think
you came from a monkey to know it's
addictive. I know. You know, this
is how crazy these liberals are.
You know that it's crazy to
think you came from monkey.
Willie's motherfuckers take it to
another level. They, they're so crazy.
They think you came from a shrew. He were
a lack. A little mole cannot here. Yep,
Yep, Yep, Yep, Yep. And
then that became a monkey.
And then add the monkey becomes you all
that shit inside of 65 million years.
Get the fuck Outta here. Fuck. Meanwhile,
crocodiles are a hundred million
years old. So crocodiles are the same.
But somehow or another,
we went from being a fucking shrew to
being a person who knows and loves Jesus
and her heart shit. That's it
right there. That's that thing.
So if you see like rats, like
there was a, I don't buy it.
I think it was in, where
was it? There was a video.
We were a science experiment.
There was a video of rats in Chinatown.
I th I want to say
it might've been northern California,
but there was,
they were tearing down a building in
Chinatown and the volume of rats that come
pouring out of this building, it's like,
hold on, say that Shit. They did what?
They were living in the
walls of this building,
it demolish it and all the rest came out.
They were demolishing it and
people were outside filming.
As you're seeing like streams of rats
run out of this building and out onto the
street, stumbling into the gutter,
standing there on the sidewalk,
not knowing where to go and fucking
hate rats are running past him,
but I mean hundreds of rats,
hundreds, probably thousands
if they're in the walls.
Right?
For sure.
For sure. Communities are rats inside
the rural walls. This building,
they're tearing down. I'm glad we
don't have rats in Los Angeles.
Not like they do in like New York.
Do you know why we don't have rats?
Cody's, that's right.
Yeah. The coyotes. Yeah.
Those motherfuckers [inaudible] mark,
creepy weird dogs that you see running
around taking all the fucking rats.
Those who don't quit be cons. They
keep us in check. What do you,
what did you find Jamie?
Do you find the rat video with all the
other video about by found like this one
lady said she thought she was going to
die. There were so many rats around her.
She didn't know what to do. Just
a little. Just a little much.
But it says there was a huge
problem in 91 year old building.
I can't find a video of your,
that's an l like February 9th and they
tore it down, I think. Oh Shit. Well,
if you're in the city,
I'm sure there's horrible rat problems
and I know there's rat problems in the
Hollywood hills too. Um, yeah, I, yeah,
that's your out here. There's no fun.
Somebody told me they were
at a movie theater and some,
some person who lives in the hills
had a nice house with a movie theater,
but they had to keep their feet up
when they watch movies cause rats were
running across your feet.
Shut the fuck up in their Nice
House with a movie theater. Okay,
get that shit handled called exterminator.
Get that shit handled the or get a,
get a couple more dogs. Keep your
feet up. Get more dog cats around.
When they get shit in a box in your
house, just piss in a box. A little dog.
Does Marshall or eat little
critter things? He does. He
bring him into the house.
He loves kill squirrels. Would joke
around about it. He's a squirrel killer,
but he's a straight up squirrel,
killer murderer. He's so sweet,
but not the squirrels thing
is he doesn't rip them apart.
He just kills them like they're
a toy and he brings him back.
I don't think he understands what the
fuck they are. No, he doesn't fuck up.
But he brings him back and then what
does he put them in the same spot.
Every time you bring your ball back,
they'll drop in this bottle being
a squirrel bag drop in this bar.
Like they returned things.
Yeah, he's a retriever.
Well he just wants to know if
you want this. No, no, he's
a retriever. Yeah, go get,
that's what those dogs are.
Those dogs are designed probably
for like duck hunting or some shit,
like whatever, whatever retrieval that
you wanted them to do. But they, they're,
they don't crush things. They have a
gentle mouth. They call it a soft mouth.
Like when they carry things they
don't like I've had pimples. Right.
And they just crush everything.
They merge everything you give them.
I had a dog that I had to give him
a fucking root canal. Not, I did it.
I brought him to an actual dentist
show the dentist. He, he bits so hard.
He shattered his teeth. He shattered his
back, his back teeth. Ah, by crushing,
um, uh, bones. It just
was crushing, just going,
since they have so much power
that their teeth would crack.
But the cold retrievers don't
bite that heart. They don't bite.
That's like Brittany's, my dad's
friend had a Brittany, a hunting dog.
Brittanys are like that too.
They're gentle and put a duck
in their mouth or something,
but they won't buy exactly. Like you
can't go duck hunting with a pit bull.
So bring you back a hamburger patty.
Like it happened to duck you fucking
asshole. And it's like, Shit,
get it shock rip to fucking
shreds. Yeah. Do you have,
you want a dog?
You don't want a German shepherd that does
bite work to go out and get your docs,
whatever retriever.
I mean,
it's not a coincidence that those
dogs like labs and retrievers,
they're like the sweetest dogs in the
world. There's so nice to people. Yeah,
because it, because they're, I think
they're inherently like their whole,
they're not a vicious attack.
They don't like attacking. I'm,
I've never seen a of golden attack, so,
no, no, no. They're not like that at all.
But they're bred for that and that's
the way their bread. Like you,
you never met my dog yet. Right. She's
the fucking nicest. I, if he's in here,
he wouldn't leave you alone. Who usually
putting his head in your lap like hello?
Like he just, he'll drop to his back all
the time. Just come on. Belly rubbed me.
Like if he meets you,
he'll start whining and he runs around
in circles and then he drops his basic
rub my belly. Come on in here and you
know you went to and he just want love.
Constantly want love and
hugs. My Day. Every day.
I'm not going to lie for a long time.
Not having a dog at the
house is so strange.
And because you said when you come home
and not have anything, sometimes it's,
it's a little overwhelming. Yeah. It's
nice to have something to be like, hey,
it's great for lonely people.
Oh my God. By herself.
It makes a big difference having a dog.
Do you criminalize second? What? Wait.
It came through.
Oh my God.
I thought you said it didn't pass this
morning and said it didn't it 15 minutes
ago.
Shit.
Denver became the first city in
the u s to decriminalize marijuana.
Wow. Powerful Denver. Wow.
Holy Shit Man.
It passed for voters approved measure
decriminalized psychedelic mushrooms can.
Congratulations.
Amazing.
How did we think they eat better
information? You son of a bitch.
They were staying at all
night for some reason.
They did say son of a bitch.
Jamie working with the CIA.
Still unofficial apparently though as
close to it on Wednesday afternoon,
ended up pulling 51 pulled
ahead this afternoon.
That's why this morning it wasn't
a head and then they still,
they're still counting votes.
The provisions prohibit the
city government or using
any resources to impose
criminal penalties against adults over
21 years of age or personally he's
possession of psychosocial seven hey,
you don't have to talk about
during the end of a commercial.
What do you want to do it? You have to
get it all out just in case. No, no, no.
This is not a discount.
What if something hits us
and kill somebody knows the
fuck you just said. Yeah,
it is. That's just the funny thing
about those commercials and the flood.
A little, little, little, little,
little [inaudible] doing it so fast they
can't because they just easily get it
out legally. It's gray, but it's so
gross. Yeah. They just have to get it out.
When I first started hearing that,
I'm like,
there's a job for fast talking
bullshitters it's safe like the rapper Mac
lethal. Not that he's a
fast talker and bullshitter,
but he wrapped so fast and uh,
do you know he is? Yeah. Dude,
he could barely hear half of
the shit comes out of his mouth.
You can hear it pretty clear.
Sometimes pretty fucking clear.
Pretty fucking. When he does the wraps in
the morning. I've seen some of his shit.
Dude, that's a talent. Yeah, that's,
I mean the way he does it is
incredible. Yeah. He's got dunning.
Like I hear it and I just go,
I don't even understand how the
fuck tongue can move that fast,
but it makes sense. Like do you ever
do something with your right hand?
Like he'd go like this really fast
and I'll try it with your left hand.
It's like they can't do it all.
It's like, yeah, like I can,
I can tap this real fast but I can't,
I can't really do with my left hand.
Exactly. That's tapping
is a good example. Yeah.
You got to think that your face
is like that too, but your mouth,
it's got to be quick. You gonna
Move Advisor won't Pfizer, Pamela.
I went to an auction basically.
Hey,
otherwise I've got to ride dad. Dad.
Keeping up with your face with
the noises is that same skill.
It's the same way that a buffer brothers
were able to do that thing that they're
able to do. No, there's something,
there's something about it. I know,
but there's something about it.
Well,
there's definitely something
about the rhythm that he does.
The rhythm that he announces this. It's
like, it's so specific that you're like,
wow, this is really, it's such a unique
talent. Bruce is different than anybody.
Anybody that's ever done that kind of
shit because he gets fucking crazy.
Like he's perfect for MMA.
He gets so amped up because most people
are just professional in the red corner
coming from Los Angeles,
California, stitch it up.
Joe Schilling,
you know what I mean?
But Bruce fucking screen,
he goes fighting. Yeah.
The way he yells. It's
so fucking true. Ooh.
He gets crazy perfect for MMA.
It must amp up the fight are so fucking
much they might do when they hear your
name, you're just going to be like,
and he's almost having a heart attack.
If he takes to tend to
have a heart attack,
Bruce buffer gets to five every fucking
show. Look at them there. I mean,
he's not dying.
He's in great shape,
but he gets to halfway to a heart
attack every fucking time. Like,
look, I'll ready gets bro. I mean
you, he's putting it out there.
That's why he's so much different than
any other ring announcer ever because you
can't just do that. Like if you
go back and watch his early days,
he wasn't really doing it like that.
Like she developed his style.
Look how cool that is,
man.
Him and Tj Dillashaw fucking bombed out.
Pumped.
Is he right there?
That's telling you about
Bruce buffer pumps people the
fuck up, man. Look at that.
That's intense, man. That's
intense. Whoo. That's so exciting.
He's awesome. He said she character
too, man. He's perfect suits.
He's always got a different
one. Yeah, he's always looking.
She always looks sharp,
sharp as long as it's real fucking shot.
But it's interesting that like that
style of announcing really didn't exist
before Bruce. Right. And
before MMA, like it didn't,
it was not appropriate for boxing.
Like he had this air of old man class
kind of still that you had to abide by
these rules and they still have a bell
thing come out and hit the bell with the
thing. Well I mean, I mean w the would
clap still happens across the board for,
for boxing and MMA. Yes. Yes. Warning.
Second warning is still a thing.
Yeah.
Like how come they have an upgraded
that to a sound? I don't understand.
What's a good quote? That's a good point
because sometimes people get confused.
It's happening even with professionals
and they misinterpret the would clap as
being the end of the round because just
cause they're so in the groove right
there.
Like what happened did that was at the
end of the round and they'll stop and the
ref go now I'll keep going
and you have 10 seconds left.
And then like sometimes weird stuff
happens where guys get out of their mental
pattern. Sure. It's happened many times.
It's got to also be the noise of
an arena sometimes can take over.
I'm sure something gets
distracted here that you think,
was that a yell or was that the clap?
Like do
I have 10 seconds left her dewine so
we're going to be in Chicago for that big
fight. Fucking oh shit was going
to be fine. What does that, June,
what does that, what does June 8th
right? June 8th. Right now I don't,
I don't think there's any tickets
left if anybody wants. No,
I doubt it pretty close. But there's
a, that's a big UFC card too, isn't it?
Who's on that car? Uh, I just saw this
morning, I just looked this morning,
Henry Cejudo versus Marlin Mariah's
for the bantamweight title. Ooh.
She has the opportunity
to become champ champ.
And then I'm Ma Marlin rise.
Fucking fantastic fighter. Yeah,
that's a great card. Jimmy
Rivera. Petra Yawn. Yawn.
Pyotr I think it's just,
we'll say the pure to pure Tra fuel truck,
Russian character. Valentina Shevchenko
versus Jessica. I, that's great. Fight to,
um, that's such a great name. So chanko
yeah. Such a great fucking Badass.
I fuck you up. Name that. Hold
on. Stop scrolling back up.
It's Tatiana Suarez is a B stew.
That woman is so good.
She's probably the best
wrestler in female MMA.
She smashes people and need
an Sar off is fantastic.
That's a great fight. That's um,
Amanda Nunez. His girlfriend too.
Amanda Nunez is probably the
baddest woman. Literally ever. Oh,
we met her, right? Yeah, she
was at the last, she's the
one that knocked out. Cyborg.
Cyborg was the baddest woman in MMA when
Amanda Knew Nunez starched her in the
first round. There's no one you
could literally legitimately
give that title too.
It's Amanda Nunez.
She's the baddest woman ever.
Aljamain sterling versus page on Munoz.
That's a gray card.
Ricardo Lamas. Calvin or that's
a great fight to shit. A lot of,
a lot of chicks. A lot of checks be
fighting. A lot of Chicago girls.
It's not Chicago girls angry
for getting ready to fly.
Tamp fucking tie into this town.
That's you guys. That's Boston.
Chicago girls are more, I don't know
how to say the Chicago. Chicago's no,
fuck a talented. He's Tan. Kiss my ass.
I'll fuck you up drill. Say That I ass.
Yeah.
Fuck you.
Chicago is an interesting combination
with like Midwest and urban,
like it's a city. It's like, it's
like cosmopolitan. It's sophisticated,
but it's also the city in the Midwest.
That's what it is. It wouldn't be. Yeah,
that's right in the middle
of fucking Ohio Turd.
So they get so jealous when we say that
Columbus has an argument that it might
be better than Chicago.
No other city in the Midwest has an
argument that a lot of people that that's
like where you would graduate from if
you've got tired or too big for Columbus
and he move over to see how far you drive.
Six hours.
It's not bad to make it to San
Francisco. Yeah. It's not bad at all.
But all the cities in the Midwest
compete with Chicago and they all know.
They fucking know. I mean, it
was who would be, who would
beat us? Who'd be better?
Detroit, Kansas City, St Louis.
Detroit's in a bad spot. Indianapolis.
None of these places have
the things that we have.
Don't kick Detroit while it's down. No,
no. I like to try to what you're doing,
I them, they're just not as much tone.
Their industry fell apart and Chicago,
Milwaukee, I mean all these other
cities, they're great cities,
but I'm not Chicago.
Really crazy is that Detroit in the
1950s was the richest city in the world.
Sure. World. Yeah. It's
a lot of wealth up.
They're getting so many people
in the automotive industry. Well,
that time when they were at the top of
the automotive industry and they were
making cars that were coveted throughout
the world and all the manufacturing was
done there, she wasn't the richest
city in the world at one point in time.
Now it's one of the poorest. It's less
than a century later. It's really crazy.
There's not another city like that
that hasn't had like some sort of a
catastrophe, like something hit
it like it just went away. Yep.
Detroit as, I mean I, it's
actually a wonderful fucking city.
I actually do love to try it. It
is really sad. Yeah. It's sad.
When you go up there cause you,
you see remnants of what was,
it's really strange to see what,
what happened with GM and all that shit.
You could buy a house for $100
that's not funny. Now you can kind of
a bitch. Why you laughing? You must be,
don't tell me jokes person.
I think it's funny that you
could buy a house when you,
while you can't buy a
house out here for fucking,
you can't even buy a house for a
hundred grand. Nope. Not even people.
We tell people that like you can't buy
a house for $100,000 it's like, no,
you can't. And impossible.
I think a what? Impossible.
Like if you live in Sugarland,
Texas,
you can get a pretty decent house
for like 150 grand, like Nice House.
Not here. Not Fuck that. Not even
close people. What's the what?
What is it like in Ohio cheap looking
on Detroit. Zillow. This is $1,000.
It's foreclosed though.
Thousand Bucks. It's nice house.
Let's go there and start a podcast studio,
our next podcast,
studio downstream match.
And if we just decided to do that,
we decided to armor plate a fucking
house. Have a guard there, 24,
seven and helicopter in. We'll fly in
brow this regular flights to Detroit,
and then we have a Detroit version
of our podcast and kind of fun,
but we have to wheel in our electronics
or they'll try to steal it. Yeah,
I mean that's just not smart.
Detroit is like too dangerous.
We have to go somewhere more rural, but
also ridiculous. Can we go main? Yeah.
Main Bank. Gorman far out. Oh, come
on, bro. Don't be scared, man. C'Mon.
Let's go somewhere close.
We'd get all those cool people
from northern California.
Let's go up to like, uh,
like, like, like, like Napas area.
Like, hmm. Okay. Well let's go.
But that plays burns every couple of
years. Bad. Yeah, I guess it does. Yeah.
What about, okay, well what, what
by the ocean? We'll do like Carmel,
Carmel by the sea. You tuffle
C'mon. Let's see. Hormel's gorgeous.
I like how you're talking. That's where
Clint Eastwood film play misty for me.
That's where he lives, right? Well,
he was the mayor of Carmel. Oh Shit.
He won your mayor.
Can't it can't stop that guy.
Why aren't we going where
the mushrooms illegal? Oh,
too many people to move in in
Denver, man. Too many people,
too many people are moving with that.
Look it up.
Look it up about Denver's problem
with their infrastructure.
They're hating how many people are
coming into their city. Listen Bro,
you moved to evergreen live
in the mountains. Savage.
I'll move to Breck Elvis
album to breakfast.
How about Aspen? That's a rich. When he
coke Breckenridge is nice. I like Breck.
Don't you want to see y'all girls yelled
or boyfriends and scream out in this
treat with naked
is we need more money.
Is the mushroom legality,
is that going to be like a doctor thing?
Are they going to like, no,
it's deep. Criminalized is,
is that you don't go to go. You don't go
to jail but you can't sell it legally.
It's very squirrely but it's what it
is is step one and that's what we need.
We need step one and then it's also
on the ballot in California soon.
And when it's on the ballot in California,
soon it has a likelier chance here.
I think that even in Denver and more
so now the real problem is people don't
understand what it is. Right. And
they think it's just like, oh my God,
these kids going to do mushrooms
are gonna drive off cliffs.
That's what people worry about.
You can do more testing now. Right?
Is that sort of what it helps?
Well, they've done some tasks.
Johns Hopkins University had some pretty
extensive testing that they did that
showed,
um,
real positive results with people
that had terminal illnesses where it
alleviated the worry of death.
And um,
there was some other studies
that had been run on it,
but there's so far no one
has ever instituted in the
United States at least like
a real thorough,
comprehensive clinic where you can go and
they can treat you if you have alcohol
addiction,
Ptsd.
There's a lot of different things
they could treat with psilocybin.
And it's been illegal
because it's a schedule one
substance. So all these people,
it's one of the best
things on earth to fix,
like mental barriers and
problems that you have,
especially if it was done in a controlled
clinical environment by people you
trusted and you felt safe. And that's
what a shaman is supposed to be, right?
What a shaman is supposed to be.
So many provides you with the psychedelic
substances in a controlled state with
they, they let you be in a good state
of mind set and setting is always very,
very important.
And if we could do that,
I mean I really think we have a real
good chance of turning a lot of people
around. People that are
addicted to things, people
with psychological problems,
people that can't see themselves should
have a lot of, lot of different issues.
And it's one of the best tools for that.
But like every tool, it could be abused,
but the problem is not the tool.
The problem is abused,
whether it's with alcohol or pills
or food or any of these things.
We're talking about sex.
People can abuse anything of course,
but it doesn't mean that silicide
and isn't in an amazing compound that
literally can change humanity.
It can.
Yeah, it has. It has. It does.
And there's so many other,
there are so many other things
that we don't even know.
We haven't even tapped
into the possibilities.
That's the other thing was when you
limit yourself on the possibilities,
it's like, well, we don't,
how do we know what happens?
How do you know what it's going to do?
What if the chip releases mushroom juice
every 15 minutes? A little micro dose.
Just a little micro dose. No, it feels
your levels when you start getting angry.
When they got cuts me off and I'm like,
you fucking asshole releases and I'm
like, a little bit of God
juice. I'm fine. You are fine.
Aren't you going somewhere this weekend?
Were you at when Vegas? Oh Jesus.
Would he do in Vegas? What
are you doing? Jimmy Kimmel.
Just open up and call it out there.
Do you think it was from Vegas and he
opened up a comedy club, I think. Uh,
what day are you there? Uh,
Friday, Thursday, Friday, Saturday.
And who you work with, you
know, uh, I'm taken, uh,
taken young Ari Mannis
excellence. Excellence. Yeah.
Be a Vegas and then two weeks ago
to rally before I go to Chicago,
I got up Charlie. Good night. Good nights
baby. Oh, it's just good nights now.
I think it's about, yeah, just
good night's comedy. He brought it,
but it's the same, same setup. Same Shit
to beautiful club raw. That's another one.
That small kind of intimate, it's a
two legged two, two l Raleigh's great,
great town. I got family from North
Carolina, so I'll be seeing some north.
That's like a really cool town. Cool.
College towns. Hip. Yes. The vibe.
The vibe is really cool. The
vibe. The five is cool, cool.
Cats out there and no smoking.
Cigarette painting,
chill and making jazz man.
That's who they are.
Shows Cooler which shows like that
all the time, man. Which I was a cat.
Get a champion. You'll be together.
You'll get a little bit for advice.
Just ask me anything man.
Magic chips become the new law.
Bottomy like in the future they were,
I can't believe these people let
themselves get chipped and the chip just
deteriorates inside of you and
starts rotting your NeuroQore.
We start to fucking slowly, slowly
turn into machining. You, you,
you can read minds for the first
10 years, Denny, get Parkinson's.
Fuck sacrifice dude. You thinking in 10
years I'll fix it. I'll fix it by then.
10 years.
We do that all the time.
It's not a cure by the time
that we're done with it.
I've seen people say that about
cigarettes. I think, you know,
I wish I didn't have to smoke, but I do.
And I'm thinking they're going to fix it.
They're going to fix it with medics,
mate.
I've got to fix it with
Madison about Jules.
What about these electronic cigarettes?
That's next close.
They're so close to being able to
reverse cancer by the time I get cancer,
my mother, I dunno, my mother's going to
die from cancer, but maybe not me. Not me,
not me, bro. All these other
younger generation does
suck and not the electronic.
The robot. Dick's. I think that's going
to kill him. I Dunno. That's going to,
I think there's gonna be some shit in
there. Did you pens? Fuck yeah, thanks.
How do you know what's in those
you ask and they'll tell you.
Why are they lying to you then why would
they tell you? Cause you're so stupid.
You're willing to smoke a robot. Did they
tell you the truth of what's in there?
You think they're going to keep
selling them? They could sell them.
They had skulls and crossbones on it
with a, with a person with x's for eyes.
Like right there. Like people die
from this. This, yeah. Choke to death.
Cigarettes like cigarettes in Europe,
they have the packet they had,
they've show pictures of people with
like lung cancer. Oh this happens.
People at giant warnings not telling
me. Oh. Fark Foskett keeps smoking.
Did you ever smoke when you
were young? No, I tried it.
I tried it when I was 15 me and my
sister tried it. She kept smoking.
She smoked for years and now she's quit.
She quit.
Eventually she quit when she had
kids. What about, what about a robot?
Cigars. You never smoked cigars? Yeah,
I like cigars. I smoke cigars. Yeah.
I used to have some here,
but I don't want anymore and none of them.
Well now they have weed in them.
Yeah. It wasn't my favorite sectors.
It's a different thing like the cigar
with no weed is like that speedy kinda
relax. See, weird high. People don't
know. If you don't smoke cigars,
you get high. This is why like
Republicans who are anti-drug,
who smokes cigars and like whiskey,
shut your dirty mouth. You're on drugs.
Okay, they, these are, you're
on a substance. Yeah. You're,
you're altering your state of
consciousness. With cigars,
they give you a certain
amount of euphoria. Nicotine,
you get that little buzz from the high,
like I used to smoke cigars
all the time with Kevin James.
Kevin James doesn't fuck with weed.
He doesn't really drink,
but he will smoke the shit out
some cigars and we got fucked up.
They fuck you up. They do. They do in
a weird way or over that, that it's,
it's overwhelming. There are a
lot. They're heavy. It's a lie.
You just want to kind of like,
I'd like him after a fat steak and I want
to feel like an ugly American of a fat
Ribeye and then a fucking cube and
sit on a porch and just
talk shit with your friends.
You know have a glass of whiskey.
Yeah and that's a like
a non self aware high.
Like sometimes you don't want to be,
you don't want to be like not even
self awareness is the wrong term when a
really looking for is like self analysis.
You're not an analyzing yourself and you
smoking a cigar and drinking whiskey.
You have fun. Yeah. Just
hanging a comeback kicking
back and your brain's not,
your brain's kind of turned
off and you do those things.
It's not turned on like the,
the problem with the weed is all
the good things about the weed.
The weed is good because it makes
you think and it makes you paranoid.
It makes you aware and yeah,
he makes you more compassionate.
It makes you more contemplatives
and makes you more self analytical.
But it also could freak out sometimes
and maybe that's not what you want that
day. Maybe that day you just want
to Hoyle de Monterrey double corona.
Just puff on that bad boy.
You ever inhale?
Look now at glass of Buffalo.
Trace with a big fucking ice cube.
I swear to you Peshy when
a big fucking nice big fat.
Whenever we go and get drinks. Andrew
Santino asks, how big are your ice cube?
This? We asked like a
whiskey, but you have a,
do you have a large queue of one
stone and I always look away like this
motherfucker and aids. I said, do you
have one stone? I just want one stone.
So high maintenance. He wants
a large ball. It got a ball.
Can you get me a nice ball?
Yeah,
with the fur balls of ice
because you know what they do.
Otherwise they scoop a fuck load of ice
in there and it dilutes the whiskey and
it's all water. I don't like it.
No. My friend John Dudley does,
it wasn't play games. He takes a
pan of water, like a large pan,
and then he puts it in the trade or grills
and he sets it to super smoke and the
smoke is constantly pumping into the
water. It leaves it there for hours.
Then he takes that smoke filled
water and he pours it into those
ball.
So he makes those molds with
smoke infused water. I love him.
Then he puts dat in the glass and
the Whiskey, he knows and I'm like,
Whoa, that's next level.
And like that shit smoked.
It smoked and you gotta break up. You're
supposed to break those bottles on hand.
Yeah. Who is it? WHO's out
there doing that? What does
that, oh, that's the wedge.
I've seen this. Yeah. What is
this? Communism. What does it it?
It's half ice. Half glass.
Get that shit out of my face.
God Damn hippies. Fucking hippies.
What else? You got your own cold brew.
Ha. Yeah. Homemade. That's like, go to
see if you could find you want to be,
prove your wizardry skills
cause I know he has them. Yeah.
Try to find John Dudley smoked
ice balls on the Instagram.
Good luck. He'll find it. He'll find
it within sex. Rager smoke balls.
He calls him smokey balls. So he
makes him doesn't himself. Yeah,
he makes it doesn't himself
like in his backyard.
And he started already got I got, I got
to bring it up to see if it makes sense.
I can't,
if he gave me time,
I wouldn't be able to convince
her if I can't do that shit.
He was doing it while he's operating
the camera. So here's John's, uh,
he's going to grill running. So he's
got that, that pan fill with water.
There is smoke in it.
Yeah. And, and this is a,
he's got the insulated top
on it because he's in Iowa.
It's freezing fucking cold.
And then he pours that
smokey water into the molds.
Dun, Dun, Dun. Okay. Balls
trying to give fucked up kids.
Ooh.
Smoky balls, Cat Lady.
That crazy shit. So yeah,
that was when we were in Lanai when we
were little. And I, John, John and I have,
we've tied it on, man.
We've tied it on many times,
but we did one podcast with a bunch
of bow hunters and we got fucked up.
We're drinking everything in the mini
cabinet and a w the minibar had red bull
and red wine and Tequila and a,
what else?
Die Coke and John Dudley mix it
all up and call it a cat lady.
Cause just like some crazy shit fucked
up. And we were all drinking. I had no,
there was no diet coke.
It was red bull Tequila and red wine.
That's what it was.
It was the damn delicious.
What are so trashy?
I was going to say when we were high as
fuck and we're just trashed trying to go
to your fucked up. The kids who do
the suicide, you know that every,
every fucking kind of soda
and the machine. It's only
good because you're like,
Eh, this is supposed to be fun. We were
just having a good time doing a podcast,
you know, having a good time. Just
drinking ridiculous shit. Bullshit.
Yeah,
the Cat Lady,
it's going to be a thing because now
the internet is gonna be like, well,
I want to make a cab was a thing
for a while. People were doing it,
but then they realize why would you do
that when you could have a Margarita or
have a peer that actually
raised him on their own? Yeah.
Have a nice glass of wine by itself.
It's just some shit you do when you're,
you know, you're scratching your
and scavenging and a mini bar.
Whenever you get bored in high,
you create like the most,
I saw someone on the Internet posted.
They took the ice cream from an ice cream
sandwich and then rice to Rice Krispie
treats and they put the ice cream
between is it was an ice crispy treat.
Someone wants them for diabetes.
Aubrey,
I think we can go with the Burrito
that like ice cream burrito.
It's going around. I seen that candy and
ice cream and shit. That shit's gross.
Cub Swanson turned a double double
from in and out into a Taco.
What?
Yeah.
He chopped up a double double and put
it into a taco shell asked from me to
remember us talking about it, whether
or not that's okay. Blasphemy.
You can't fuck with it in and
out. Push things along. God,
how was that Shit? Taco Bell.
Fucking gross. Gross. Well foul.
Anybody that eats Taco bell living in
Los Angeles, a shameful human being.
The amount of good Mexican food
just so it's like it's too much.
There's too much good.
What is happening here?
Turn 200 McDonald's burgers
into a Burrito. Yeah, this guy,
the mealtime guys,
they've been doing this for a while.
I've been doing this for 10 years. They
stuff it in there. And what is the wrap?
Is that a Burrito wrap and then
Kevin need to see this. Jamie. Jamie,
I want to look at your search engine.
I would take away your right to vote.
I'd be like, there's no way.
Like at different computers.
What's wrong with you?
That's why it got different.
That's why I got different computers.
You don't see my other ones, Dan, you.
I don't know why anybody
now I have different emails.
This is Mr. Happy Easter.
Happy Lines to get on. This one only
looks for happy things. Flowers,
different personality for different
computers. This is Mr Dirty.
This is what I really like.
I like the best organic fertilizer.
It just hurt the environment.
You live in La. Where
would you live? And if we,
we all moved together, where should
we go to questions either. Well,
it's gotta be somewhere where there's
no state income tax because you're tired
of this shit. Tired of this bullshit.
But what if you start making more money?
You don't give a fuck anymore.
But still it's kind of like,
why am I paying any more
money to the fucking,
so plenty of homeless people
around. Okay. All right, fine.
Someone's going to fix the streets too.
Are they? When are they going to start?
It looks good. That's why a lot of
athletes operate out of Florida.
I drove here today and it
didn't bother me at all. Yeah,
you live so close to here.
I live on the roof live in Florida
because of low income tenants.
Say operational business out of
this is why Oj is, they're like,
they can't get you if you owe
money. Florida kick at you. Yeah.
You can hide in Florida if you
owe money. Really? Yeah. Yeah.
It's one of them weird ones, so I've
trumped nationals down there. Well,
I think that's like pensions and shit.
Like they can't take away your pensions.
Right?
They probably have some weird like union
restriction law that they can't touch
your stuff. I think. I don't really, I
don't know if I could live in Florida,
but yeah, you could. Yeah,
you would just mock it.
Me and oatmeal and John Travolta and he
lives in a collar one right next door to
him. He always offer massages and
shit and he'd be like, Nah, I'm good.
You want to jump on a plane? Fly To dance
together. You and me just fly. Fuck.
I don't know man.
John Travolta wants to be my friend.
Do you think he's just wants
to be my friend? He just
said, buddy, he's a good guy.
He's got a [inaudible]. Oh No,
we have to land in the water.
We'll have to hold each other
for warmth for awhile. Oh,
how long for like four days.
Maybe fall inside you and keep you warm
or from the inside by Dixon your ass.
They might come rescue me as turns. Very
hot. I know that sounds crazy, but it's a,
it's a different change of life and death.
Got to put it inside.
If you put your mouth on my
penis, it, it heals. You'll see.
It's like over a hundred degree. Blow
me up and then ride me as we float away,
blowing me up like a balloon.
His playground scenario or Volta.
I don't know where I would live probably.
I mean Chicago is an easy answer.
I really want to move back to Chicago.
I love it.
You don't mind the winters,
you bond something about the bonding
that happens in the winter in Chicago.
I believe that too. You have like
a cultural bond with people. Man.
There's nothing better than going to a
bar in the winter in Chicago and it's
fucking gross and sad and cold outside
and everyone is having a good time.
Everyone wants to read
together in these moments.
It's true,
but you don't want to live in the south
side where the bullets are going off
left. And Ryan, I'll let you know
nowhere near this. How do they stop that?
I was talking to a guy who was a cop
and he was telling me that it's a,
they arrested certain gang members,
like certain people that
are running the gangs,
gang leaders and they created a power
vacuum and then they start fighting.
Then it got even more chaos.
It got way worse.
But at the cops have tried to work
with gangs over the years in a million
different ways to try to like curb the
violence. They did it here in Los Angeles.
How'd they do it?
They have these people,
they have these people that are like these
community organizers who like run the
neighborhood and they have these like
kind of peace talks with these gang
leaders to tell them like certain ways
to operate in within the community
because they're like, your kids live
here, you're with your girlfriends.
So it it for some reason I think there's
been a lot of weird cultural movements
in La, uh, that have helped.
Like, you know, Nipsey, uh,
Nipsey Hussle got shot and I think all
these crips showed up with blood and
other people came together.
I think it was this weird coming together
of gangs and this has happened in La a
few different times or
community organizers kind of
started like peel back these
walls of like,
we also have to live here.
I know you want to function
as an organization, but I
think Chicago is reckless.
I don't think it's,
I think it's less about gangs in Chicago.
It's more about young people with guns
who want control and I don't think
they're all parts of gangs. I just think
this is, it's a, it's a violent city.
It's an angry violence that it's a lot
of, a lot of poverty, a lot of poverty.
And you live there most of your life.
So what,
what's the consensus
thinking of how to fix it?
I don't know, man. I
wish. I wish I had like a,
I wish I felt like I knew what
would help that kind of stuff.
But I'm just a fucking white
guy from the north side.
You know like the majority
of these people are black.
The majority of the south side is black
and the majority of the violence and the
crime that happens in that community is
driven around these pockets of the south
side. I have no relatability.
That's the problem. Right,
but what did they think is the way to
fix it? Shit, I don't fucking know. Look,
if you are the king of the world,
what would you do to fix the crime and
south side for the last thing that we
talk about on this podcast, I would
do if it was me, if I was trying,
if I really tried to think world
president puts him, puts him Tino.
If I could put some more money in
there and get some programs in there,
start helping people.
I don't know what it is.
I don't know what the specific thing and
typical liberal you think it's going to
be fixing and money. These motherfuckers
and they wonder why Trump won.
Well they always say like
[inaudible] gonna take away the guns.
Never gonna take away the guns.
It's never going to work.
You've got to make some kind of
program that helps people function.
I don't know what it is. I'm not
that smart. I'm not that smart.
But I do think there's,
I do think there's a way to fix it,
but I do think there's also a lot of
young kids who would get guns in Chicago
and they kill people. Uh, it's going
to be a slow process of change forever.
Obama couldn't do shit.
A lot of them from Chicago,
a lot of those community organizers in
Chicago were mad at him cause he didn't
fix anything because people in the black
community where like you promised you
would fucking help a little
bit. And then it, look,
this is the first year I think we've had
a dip in murders in Chicago and we're
coming up on the summer.
So we'll see the summer's party
telling a few Yvonne bit. We'll see.
We'll say. We'll say people got guns, man,
you Santina let's wrap this bitch up.
Bring it home.
Cheeto Santino on the
Instagram and on the Twitter.
Andrew Santina,
[inaudible] dot com that's my website.
That's your mother fucking website.
Come see me.
We'll be in Los Vegas this weekend
at Jimmy Kimmel's, comedy club
sisters,
and then next weekend, two
weekends at rallies. Two
weekends in a row. No, no, no.
I'm saying into week in Vegas and then
the next weekend and then the following
and we're in Chicago. Let
and bitches know. All right.
That's going to be fun as fuck. Good
bye everybody. Until we meet again.
Jamie,
you pulled up some of those.